हेलो एवरीवन
एंड फर्स्ट ऑफ ऑल वेरी गुड इवनिंग टू
ऑल। सबको मेरी आवाज सुनाई दे रही
है? आई एम ऑडिबल।
ओके। थैंक यू। तो थोड़ा सा वेट करते हैं
स्टूडेंट्स का ज्वाइन होने का और मुझे एक
मिनट का समय दीजिए। तब तक मैं अपनी लैब का
कनेक्शन बना लेता हूं।
शुभम क्या हुआ? रजिस्ट्री का कांसेप्ट
मैंने समझाया था। कोई डाउट है तो आप मुझसे
पूछ सकते हैं।
यह काम करते हैं।
शुभम काम करते हैं।
यह हेलसास आपके ऑथेंटिकेशन प्रोसेस के
टाइम पर काम करता है। जब मैंने आपको
बोर्डिंग प्रोसेस बताया था तो उस टाइम पर
एक प्रोसेस यह भी स्टार्ट होती है।
सिमिलरली वर्क नहीं करते शुभम सिमिलरली
वर्क नहीं नहीं करते।
ओके। अच्छा यूडी साइबर सिक्योरिटी एकडमी
वाले हमारे पास पढ़ने के लिए इसलिए आते
हैं ताकि अपने चैनल पर वीडियो बना सकें।
बना सकें इसलिए आते
हो। वेरी
गुड। जस्ट गिव मी सेकंड।
देयर आर ओनली हाउ मेनी स्टूडेंट्स दे 20
स्टूडेंट्स ओके
ओके देखो सिक्योरिटी प्रोवाइडर आपको यह
बताता है कि कौन सा मैकेनिज्म यूज किया
जाएगा। जाएगा एलसास उसको यूज़ करता
है। समझ में आ गया शुभम?
ओके। अभी सेशन को हम स्टार्ट कर सकते हैं।
आज का जो सेशन हमारा काफी इंपॉर्टेंट सेशन
है रिगार्डिंग Windows CLI के जो Windows
की जो कमांड प्र्प होती है जैसे आप
सिमिलरली
Linux के लिए टर्मिनल का यूज करते हो
कमांड को रन करने के लिए लinक्स को ऑपरेट
करने के लिए। सिमिलरली आप क्या कर सकते
हो? Windows को भी सीएलआई के थ्रू डील कर
सकते हो। ओके? तो आज का जो टॉपिक रहेगा
हमारा Windows CLI से रिलेटेड रहेगा।
लेकिन सबसे पहले सबको पता है कि हमने
लास्ट कुछ दिन पहले वेबिनार किया था
Android पेन टेस्टिंग के लिए और काफी लोग
इंतजार कर रहे थे कि सर Android पेन
टेस्टिंग की क्लासेस कब आएंगी? कि Android
पेन टेस्टिंग की क्लासेस कब आएंगी? मैंने
आपको बताया था कि जल्दी आएंगी। तो उसका एक
वेबिनार हमने किया है। तो चैनल में भी
उसकी वीडियो लिंक आपके पास अवेलेबल्स है।
तो आई रिक्वेस्ट जिसने भी वेबिनार को
अटेंड नहीं किया था या जिसने मिस कर दिया
था तो वेबिनार को अटेंड कर सकते हो
और उसके बाद आप चाहो तो कोर्स को क्या कर
सकते हो? ज्वाइन कर सकते हो। काफी
इंटरेस्टिंग कोर्स है जिसकी ड्यूरेशन 2.5
से लेके मैक्स 3 मंथ के बीच में रहेगी
जिसमें आपको बहुत कुछ सीखने को मिलेगा।
अगर आपको नहीं पता है तो मैं आपको बता
देता हूं कोर्स कहां पर आपको देखने को
मिलेगा। जस्ट सिंपली आपको क्या करना है?
गो टू
योर वेट होल्ड
ऑन। आई फॉरगॉट माय लिंक।
आपको सिंपली क्या करना है?
defronic.com इस लिंक पर जाना है और आपको
क्या करना है?
यहां पर आप देख सकते हो कोर्स से रिलेटेड
कोई भी जानकारी आपको चाहिए तो आपको लिंक
मैंने प्रोवाइड कर दिया है। सिंपली यहां
पर जाइए कोर्स से रिलेटेड आपके कोई भी
सवाल है तो आप यहां पर देख सकते हो क्वरी
देख सकते हो। कंप्लीट सिलेबस भी आप देख
सकते हो। तो यहां जैसे आप डाउनलोड करोगे
तो यह कंप्लीट सिलेबस है चिटशीट के साथ।
तो अराउंड 31 पेजेस का सिलेबस है जिसमें
हमने चेक ऑफ लिस्ट भी प्रोवाइड की है जो
कोर्स कंप्लीट करने के बाद आप फॉलो कर
सकते हो। यह इसका कंप्लीट कोर्स है और जो
आपको कोर्स के दौरान पढ़ाया जाएगा। जो भी
टॉपिक्स हैं, सब टॉपिक्स हैं, सब सेक्शंस
हैं और हर एक चीज आपकी हैंड्स ऑन करवाई
जाएगी। आपसे करवाया जाएगा। मैं ओनली रन
करके नहीं दिखाऊंगा। जस्ट आपको एज अ टास्क
भी उनको दिया जाएगा जो आप खुद से अपनी
मशीन के ऊपर रन कर सकते हो। यह आपका
कंप्लीट डिटेल सिलेबस है जिसको आप गो थ्रू
कर सकते हो। उसके बाद आपको क्या करना है?
जस्ट सिंपली यहां पर स्क्रॉल डाउन कीजिए।
स्क्रॉल डाउन कीजिए। उसके बाद आप क्या कर
सकते हो? अभी ऑफर्स लिमिटेड है। 30 सीट्स
अभी 30 सीट कंप्लीट नहीं हुई है। लेकिन आप
क्या कर सकते हो? अभी यह गैब कर सकते हो।
जस्ट प्री बुकिंग कर सकते हो। यह हमारा
पेमेंट गेटवे है। यहां पर आपके पास दो
ऑप्शंस हो गए। अगर आप चाहो तो वन टाइम
पेमेंट कर सकते हो। वन टाइम पेमेंट में
आपको डायरेक्ट डिस्काउंट 500 का मिलेगा।
जिसमें वन टाइम पेमेंट 6500 आपको करना
पड़ेगा। अदरवाइज कोर्स की ओरिजिनल
फीस 15,000 है। डिस्काउंट करके 10,000 से
भी हमने क्या किया? 7,000 पे उसको रख दिया
गया फर्स्ट 30 स्टूडेंट्स के लिए। उसके
बाद इस फीस को बैक टू 10,000 कर दिया
जाएगा। अगर आपके पास पैसे नहीं है
पेरेंट्स से बात करके अगर आप ईएमआई में
पैसे देना चाहते हो तो आप सिंपली क्या कर
सकते हो? ओनली मिनिमम पेमेंट आपको फर्स्ट
पेमेंट जो पे करनी पड़ेगी वो 3500 आपको पे
करना पड़ेगा। नेक्स्ट पेमेंट आपको नेक्स्ट
मंथ पे करनी पड़ेगी। इस तरीके से आपको
क्या करना है? पे करना है पेमेंट को और आप
कोर्स में ज्वाइन हो जाओगे। कोर्स हमारा
12 मई को स्टार्ट होने वाला है और जिसमें
हम तीन मंथ साथ में क्लासेस लेंगे और जो
क्लासेस की जो टाइमिंग रहेगी 8 टू 10
रहेगी नाइट में और हर अल्टरनेट डे पे
क्लास होगी। मंडे, वेडनेसडे और फ्राइडे ये
क्लासेस की टाइम रहेंग और संडे को हम डाउट
सेशन भी रख सकते हैं अगर आपके डाउट्स
होंगे तो। उसके बाद काफी डिटेल कोर्स है
तो आप चाहो तो इसको ज्वाइन कर सकते हो और
डोंट मिस द अपॉर्चुनिटी। तो जिसने भी अभी
तक कोर्स को ज्वाइन नहीं किया है, आप उस
कोर्स को ज्वाइन कर लीजिए। किसी अगर किसी
कोई भी कोर्स से रिलेटेड कोई भी डाउट्स
है, कोई भी क्वेरी है, तो आप क्या कर सकते
हो? हमें कांटेक्ट कर सकते हो हमारी
वेबसाइट पर जाके। वहां पर एक WhatsApp
ग्रुप में ऐड कर दिया जाएगा। उसके बाद
मोबाइल नंबर भी अवेलेबल्स है। आप WhatsApp
पर अपनी क्वरी भेज सकते हो। उसके बाद हमसे
आप कांटेक्ट कर सकते हो। आपका जो भी सवाल
जवाब होगा हम आपको आंसर करेंगे और आपके जो
डाउट्स हैं उनको क्लियर करने की कोशिश
करेंगे। यह कोर्स मेरे द्वारा ही पढ़ाया
जाएगा और आपको पता है कि मैं जिस भी कोर्स
को पढ़ाता हूं काफी डिटेल्स में बेसिक टू
एडवांस लेके जाता हूं। यह कोर्स एक नॉर्मल
कोर्स नहीं है। जस्ट कि आप को बता दिया
जाएगा कि यह यह परफॉर्म कर लो, यह परफॉर्म
कर लो। नहीं, बिल्कुल यह जीरो से लेकर
आपको एक एडवांस लेवल तक ले लेकर जाएगा।
इंटरमीडिएट नहीं। इसमें आप किसी भी लॉजिक
को बाईपास कर पाओगे। इवन आपकी कोई भी
एप्लीकेशनेशंस हो एपीके Android
एप्लीकेशनेशंस के ऊपर है। तो फिर भी आपको
कोई भी डाउट है तो आप वेबसाइट पे जाके
WhatsApp पे हमें हमसे क्वरी कर सकते हो।
उसके अलावा जल्दी इसकी अनाउंसमेंट भी होने
वाली है YouTube पर। उसके बाद फिर से हम
आपके डाउट सेशन जरूर लेके आएंगे। तो अभी
जो प्रेजेंट स्टूडेंट्स है देयर आर 21
स्टूडेंट्स। किसी का कोई डाउट है रिलेटेड
टू द Android पेन टेस्टिंग कोर्स। आप चाहो
तो अभी भी पूछ सकते हो नेक्स्ट वन मिनट
में। अदरवाइज मैं आप आज का जो हमारा टॉपिक
है वो कमांड सीएमडी के ऊपर। उसको हम काफी
डिटेल्स में सीखने वाले हैं। बहुत सारी
कमांड्स हैं जो मैं आपको काफी डिटेल्स में
बताने वाला हूं। कौन-कौन सी कमांड्स आप
सीएलआई के ऊपर रन कर सकते हो Windows की
क्योंकि Android की सॉरी Linux की कमांड्स
आपको बहुत सारी देखने को मिल जाएगी लेकिन
Windows की कमांड्स बहुत कम देखने को
मिलती हैं। तो आज मैं इस कोर्स में
Windows की कमांड आपको सारी मैक्सिमम
कमांड्स आपको बता दूंगा एज ए नॉर्मल
यूज़र्स या एक नॉर्मल पेंटेस्टर्स आपको आनी
चाहिए। इसका एक मेन कारण है। कोई मुझे बता
बता सकता है कि अगर मुझे Windows की
सीएलआई सीखने की क्यों रिक्वायरमेंट है?
कोई भी मुझे बता सकता
है। जो पहले बैच वाले जो स्टूडेंट्स हैं,
वह फ्री ऑफ कॉस्ट ज्वाइन कर सकते हैं। आप
कांटेक्ट कीजिए नितेश सर को। वह आपको
ज्वाइन कर देंगे। शुभम आपको बताया भी था।
किसी का कोई सवाल है तो पूछ लीजिए। उसके
बाद हम कोर्स को स्टार्ट करने जा रहे हैं।
तो मेरा एक सवाल है आप लोगों से।
अगर मुझे सॉरी मेरा सवाल आपसे यह है कि
मुझे Windows की कमांड प्र्ट या Windows
की सीएलआई के बारे में सीखना जरूरी क्यों
है? एज ए पेंटेस्टर या एज ए एथिकल हैकर।
बताइए कोई मेरे सवाल का जवाब दे सकता है।
कोई भी मेरे दोस्त
यहां पर 15 स्टूडेंट्स हैं। 20 भी नहीं
है। 15 स्टूडेंट्स हैं। तो कोई भी मेरे
सवाल का जवाब दे सकता है। कोई
भी कि हमें Windows की सीएलआई के बारे में
इंफॉर्मेशन क्यों होनी चाहिए? हमें
Windows की सीएलआई की कमांड्स क्यों आनी
चाहिए? कोई भी जवाब दे सकता है। कोई भी
बताना चाहेगा।
Windows की सीएलआई की हमें जरूरत क्यों
है? बताइए।
[संगीत]
मुझे एक बार कीबोर्ड कनेक्ट करने दीजिए।
जल्दी से बताइए तब तक
कोई बता सकता ओके सर इसमें फास्ट काम करते
हैं। ओके
सीएलआई सीएलआई द कोड टू इंस्टॉल द टूल्स
एंड फॉर कमांड्स। ओके सीएलआई
नीड है सर पेन टेस्टिंग के लिए। एग्जैक्ट
आंसर दीजिए मुझे। अगर मैं पेन टेस्टिंग कर
रहा हूं Windows ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम की, तो
मुझे सीएलआई की ज़रूरत क्यों है? जल्दी से
सीएलआई तो मुझे पता है कि हमें रिवर्स
इंजीनियरिंग या कुछ भी करना है तो हमें
सीएलआई की जरूरत पड़ेगी। बट व्हाई सीएलआई?
कमांड लाइन हमें क्यों चाहिए?
बताइए। शुभम सही बोल रहे हो। देखिए जब भी
हम Windows एनवायरमेंट को पेन टेस्ट करते
हैं। तो हमें एक्सेस किसका मिलता है?
डायरेक्टली कभी भी हमें ग्राफिकल यूजर
इंटरफ़ेस का एक्सेस नहीं मिलेगा। ओके? हमें
किसका एक्सेस मिलेगा? हमें एक्सेस मिलता
है कमांड लाइन इंटरफ़ेस का। जहां पर हमें
एक टर्मिनल मिलता है, एक सेल मिलता है।
सेल के अंदर हम क्या कर सकते हैं? कुछ
कररेक्टर्स या कुछ कररेक्टर की हेल्प से
जो कमांड बनती हैं उन कमांड को यूज कर
सकते हैं और उस मशीन को ऑपरेट कर सकते हो।
दूसरा कारण क्या है? ग्राफिकल यूजर
इंटरफेस से फास्ट होता है आपका सीएलआई।
लेकिन सबसे प्राइमरी काम सबसे प्राइमरी जो
कांसेप्ट है सीखना सीएलआई के बारे में यही
है कि आपको कभी भी ग्राफिकल यूजर इंटरफ़ेस
का एक्सेस नहीं मिलेगा Windows के केस
में। उस केस में आपको सीएलआई से काम चलाना
पड़ेगा। और एज ए पेन टेस्टर अगर आपको
कमांड लाइन इंटरफेस के बारे में कोई नॉलेज
नहीं है। अगर आपको सीएलआई नहीं आती, आपको
कमांड यूज़ करनी नहीं आती सीएलआई Windows
के ऊपर तो फिर आपका कोई फायदा नहीं है
उसको पेन टेस्ट करने का। क्योंकि जब तक
आपको यही नहीं पता कि एक डायरेक्टरी से
दूसरी डायरेक्टरी पर मैं नेविगेट कैसे कर
सकता हूं। डायरेक्टरी को चेंज कैसे कर
सकता हूं। खुद की कोई डायरेक्टरी या
फाइल्स क्रिएट करनी है तो मैं कैसे क्रिएट
कर सकता हूं। उसके बाद अगर मुझे कोई
सर्विज देखनी है, नेटवर्क की इंफॉर्मेशन
देखनी है या रजिस्टर की इंफॉर्मेशन देखनी
है या यूज़र्स को मैनेज करना है। अगर मुझे
इन सबका पता ही नहीं होगा तो
हम कैसे कर पाएंगे? सीएलआई होता है कमांड
लाइन इंटरफ़ेस हम जिसको बोलते हैं। ओके?
कैरेक्टर लाइन इन इंटरफ़ेस भी बोलते हैं।
दे आर लॉट ऑफ नेम्स। तो हम इसको कमांड
लाइन इंटरफ़ेस बोलते हैं। तो अभी Windows
के केस में आप सीएलआई कब यूज़ करते हो?
देखिए अभी मैं आपको प्रैक्टिस के लिए
Windows सर्वर 2019 को सिखाने वाला हूं।
तो अभी हम क्या इसको ज़ूम नहीं कर सकते। गो
बैक दिस इज आवर ये मेरा रिमोट कनेक्शन है।
शायद सबको दिखाई दे रहा होगा। यह मेरा
रिमोट कनेक्शन
है। इससे ज्यादा नहीं होगा ये ज़ूम।
ओके? तो, यह सबको दिखाई दे रहा है? सबको
दिखाई दे रहा है। एवरीवन? इसको थोड़ा सा
खुद से जूम कर लेना आप क्योंकि मेरे पास
कोई ऑप्शन नहीं है इसको दिखाने
का। बताइए जल्दी बताइए। मैं आपका वेट कर
रहा हूं रिस्पांस का। सबको दिखाई दे रहा
है सीएलआई कमांड लाइन इंटरफ़ेस। ओके। अभी
आप क्या कर सकते हो?
इसको सबसे पहले स्टार्ट कैसे कर सकते हो?
अगर आपके पास Windows मशीन है। सबके पास
Window मशीन होगी। अगर आपके पास Windows
मशीन है तो मैं इसको स्टार्ट कैसे कर सकता
हूं? डायरेक्टली अभी मैं इसको क्लोज कर
देता हूं। आप क्या करते हो? एक तो सर्च कर
सकते हो। ओके? आपको यहां पर क्या लिखना
है? सीएमडी। सीएमडी लिखना है और राइट
क्लिक और रन एज एन एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर हम रन
करेंगे इसको। दूसरा कैसे रन कर सकते हो?
Window R Window R में आप क्या लिखोगे?
सीएमडी। ओके। इसमें नहीं हम
इधर Window R अभी इधर हम ओपन नहीं कर पाए
लेकिन मैं अपनी मशीन की बात करता हूं।
Window R और मैं यहां पर सीएमडी लिखता
हूं। तो मैंने क्या लिखा? सीएमडी और ओपन
किया। तो इस तरीके से भी मैं क्या कर सकता
हूं? इसको ओपन कर सकता हूं सीएमडी को
कमांड लाइन इंटरफेस को Windows के। अभी
मैं आपको पावर सेल नहीं बता रहा। मैं जस्ट
ओनली एक नॉर्मल Windows मशीन होती है।
उसको उसके ऊपर कैसे हम सीएमडी के ऊपर
कमांड रन परफॉर्म कर सकते हैं। वो चीजें
मैं आपको सिखा रहा हूं। सबसे पहले मैं
आपको सिखाऊंगा कि नेविगेशन कैसे परफॉर्म
करते हैं। फॉर एग्जांपल्स यह अभी आपको
दिखाई दे रहा है। मैं इसका फों्ट का साइज
बढ़ा देता हूं। 1 मिनट। ओके दिस
वन नाउ स्मॉल साइज
ओके राइट क्लिक एंड
एडिट एंड ओके
प्रॉपर्टीज एंड फोंट साइज आई एम 28
ओके यस
यस हमने क्या किया इसका फों्ट साइज अभी
बढ़ा दिया यहां पर सबको दिखाई दे रहा होगा
और इसको मैं एक बार कोशिश करता हूं अगर
बड़ा होगा तो नहीं इससे ज्यादा हम इसको
नहीं बढ़ा सकते
रिमोट डेस्कटॉप का अपना एक साइज होता है
इसमें। चलो कोई नहीं इसको अभी फुल फुल मोड
में कर दिया। तो अभी आपको दिखाई दे रहा
होगा यह विंड सीएमडी है इसका। तो अगर मुझे
क्या करना है कि यह आपको दिखाई दे रहा है
यहां पर। इसका मतलब होता है सी ड्राइव
लोकल डिस्क सी ड्राइव के अंदर और इसके बाद
मेरी करंट लोकेशन कहां पर हूं मैं? करंट
जो मेरी डायरेक्टरी है करंट फोल्डर्स मैं
किस फोल्डर के अंदर हूं ये यहां पर शो
करता है। तो अगर मुझे ये देखना है कि इस
फोल्डर के कितनी भी कितनी फाइल्स फोल्डर्स
हैं इसके अंदर अगर मुझे इस इंफॉर्मेशनेशन
को देखना है तो इन इस इंफॉर्मेशनेशन को
देखने के लिए हम क्या करेंगे? नेविगेट
करेंगे। इस इंफॉर्मेशनेशन को देखने के लिए
हम किसको नेविगेट करेंगे? इस फोल्डर के
अंदर। तो एक कमांड होती है जिसको हम बोलते
हैं डीआईआर। डीआईआर हिट एंटर। जैसे आपने
डीआईआर किया इसका मतलब होता है कि लिस्ट
ऑल द फाइल्स एंड फोल्डर्स इन दिस करंट
डायरेक्टरी। इस करंट डायरेक्टरी के अंदर
कितने फाइल्स और फोल्डर्स हैं। अभी देखोगे
आप देखो कांटेक्ट्स, डेस्कटॉप,
डॉक्यूमेंट्स, डाउनलोड्स, फेवरेट, लिंक्स
आप इस तरीके से देख सकते हो। डीआर के साथ
बहुत सारे ऑप्शंस होते हैं। अगर आप इन
सबके एट्रिब्यूट्स देखना चाहते हो।
एट्रिब्यूट्स में क्या होता है कि ये हिडन
फोल्डर्स है या कोई जंक्शन फाइल है या कोई
डायरेक्टरी है या नॉर्मल फाइल्स ये सारी
चीजें आप एट्रिब्यूट भी देख सकते हो। यहां
पर आपको देख भी बाय डिफॉल्ट देखने को मिल
रहे हैं। लेकिन आप चाहो तो एक कमांड होती
है डीआर के साथ डी आई आर फॉरवर्ड स्लैश
हफन ए फॉरवर्ड स्लैश हफन ए इसका यूज़ कर
सकते हो। कैपिटल ए भी यूज़ कर सकते हो।
स्मॉल ए भी यूज़ कर सकते हो। हमने कैपिटल ए
का यूज़ करेंगे हम और हिट एंटर। अभी देखिए
यहां पर आपको बहुत ज्यादा डिटेल्स में
दिखाई दे रहा होगा चीजें। अभी ये देखो
यहां पर डेट किस टाइम पर यह इसका टाइप है।
किस टाइप में आपका कौन सा
एट्रिब्यूट्स की डायरेक्टरी है? जंक्शन अब
ये जंक्शन जो देखने को मिल रहा है इसका
मतलब होता है कि ये एक्चुअल लोकेशन नहीं
है। जो एप्लीकेशन डाटा यहां पर लिखा है ये
इसकी एक्चुअल लोकेशन नहीं है। एक्चुअल
लोकेशन इसकी कहां पर है? सी के अंदर यूजर
के अंदर एडमिनिस्टर ऐप डाटा रोमिंग
एक्चुअल लोकेशन इस डायरेक्टरी की ये है।
बट यहां पर क्या है? उसका एक आप लinक्स की
भाषा में सिंबॉलिक लिंक बोल सकते हो। यहां
पर उसका एक शॉर्टकट क्रिएट कर रखा है।
डीआई ये एक डायरेक्टरी है। जंक्शन है यहां
पर। उसके बाद ये देखो नेट ये सारी फाइल्स
को आपके सामने शो करेगा। अभी तक कुछ थोड़ी
बहुत फाइल आपको देखने को मिल रही थी।
लेकिन अभी आपको और भी ज्यादा देखने को मिल
पा रही है। क्यों? क्योंकि हफन ए यूज़ की
हमने डीआई आर हफन ए। कौन सी कमांड यूज़ की
थी हमने? डी आईआर हफन नहीं फॉरवर्ड स्लैश
ए। इसका मतलब क्या है? कि लिस्ट आउट ऑल द
फाइल्स एंड फोल्डर्स इंक्लूडिंग हिडंस
आल्सो सिस्टम फाइल्स विद देयर एट्रिब्यूट।
समझ में आ गया? उसके अलावा अगर आप चाहो तो
ओनली फाइल्स देखना चाहते हो और फोल्डर
नहीं देखना चाहते तो आप क्या कर सकते हो?
हफन ए तो है ही। उसके बाद आप कॉलन आप यूज़
करें कॉलन उसके बाद डी कॉलन डी आप ऐसा यूज़
करोगे तो ओनली आप फोल्डर देख पाओगे। सॉरी
ओनली फोल्डर देख पाओगे और हिट एंटर किए।
देखो अभी जो लिस्ट आपके सामने देखने को
मिलेगी यहां पर ओनली फोल्डर देखने को
मिलेगा। आपको कोई भी फाइल देखने को नहीं
मिलेगी। इस इस कमांड का क्या नाम है? डी
आई आर डी आई आर फोर स्लश ए कॉलन और डी
आपको देखने को मिल पा रहा है। उसके बाद
अगर मुझे ओनली फाइल को देखना है। बट मुझे
डायरेक्टरी फोल्डर को नहीं देखना है तो
हफन माइनस और डी लिखूंगा मैं यहां पर और
हिट एंटर। देखिए ओनली फाइल को रिप्रेजेंट
करेगा। ये किसी भी डायरेक्टरी को शो नहीं
करेगा। आप देख पा रहे हो यहां पर देखो
यहां पर आप देख पा रहे हो इस तरीके से आप
क्या कर सकते हो नेविगेट कर सकते हो ओनली
हिडन फाइल्स को देखना है तो उसके लिए भी
एक ऑप्शन होता है डी आई आर फॉरवर्ड स्लश
हफ स्लश ए कॉलन और एच का हम यूज़ करेंगे
उसके लिए हम यूज़ करेंगे एच एच मतलब ओनली
हिडन फाइल्स देखिए इसके अंदर ओनली हिडन
फाइल्स थी उनको शो करेगा वैसे आपको ये
फाइल्स देखने को नहीं मिल रही थी एंटी
यूजर डॉट डैड एंटी यूजर डॉट डॉट log वन
एंटी यूजर डॉट डॉट log टू ये सारी फाइल
आपको देखने को नहीं मिल रही थी। लेकिन अभी
आपको देख पा रहे हो बिकॉज़ ऑफ़ दिस कमांड डी
आईआर फॉरवर्ड स्लश ए उसके बाद कॉलन उसके
बाद एच इस कमांड को हमने यूज़ किया तो आप
हिडन फाइल ओनली हिडन फाइल्स को देख पा रहे
हो ना किसी अदर डायरेक्टरी हो
सबडायरेक्टरी हो देख पा रहे हो। समझ में आ
गया? इस तरीके से आप क्या कर सकते हो?
डीआईआर कमांड की हेल्प से आप नेविगेट कर
सकते हो कि इसके अंदर कौन-कौन सी फाइल्स
और डायरेक्टरीज अवेलेबल हैं।
समझ में आ गया यह चीज या यह चीज सबको समझ
में
आई को समझ में आ रहा
है बताइए
यस या नो ओके
ओके। अगर मुझे अभी क्या करना है? अभी एक
फाइल से दूसरी फाइल पर मुझे क्या करना है?
नेविगेट करना है। मुझे चेंज करना है। तो
Linux की तरह इसमें भी चेंज डायरेक्टरी
सीडी कमांड काम करती है। अभी मुझे सीडी
करना है। और किसके अंदर? एक फाइल होगी।
यहां पर आप देख पाओगे डेस्कटॉप के ऊपर। यह
रही टेक्स्ट फोल्डर। इसके अंदर मुझे
नेविगेट करना है। तो मैं कैसे करूंगा?
टेक्स्ट स्पेस टेक्स्ट फोल्डर।
ओके टेस्ट फोल्डर
ओके सॉरी सॉरी अभी ये इसमें काम नहीं कर
रहा एक मिनट
डीआईआर और मुझे नेविगेट करना है किसके ऊपर
ओके मुझे सीडी डेस्कटॉप पे जाना पड़ेगा
सबसे पहले मुझे अगर डेस्कटॉप पे है 1 मिनट
अगर मुझे एक और चीज है नेविगेट करने से
पहले अगर आपको क्लियर करना है स्क्रीन
जैसे हम लinक्स में करते हैं क्लियर
क्लियर कमांड का यूज़ करके इसमें भी हम कर
सकते हैं। कैसे? उसके लिए हम कमांड यूज़
करते हैं। सीएलएस क्लीन स्क्रीन क्लीन
स्क्रीन हिट एंटर। तो आपने क्या है?
स्क्रीन को क्लीन कर दिया। अभी आप क्या
करो? सबसे पहले आप डेस्कटॉप पे नेविगेट
करना चाहते हो। सीडी डेस्कटॉप सीडी
डेस्कटॉप हिट एंटर किया। आप क्या आ गए?
डेस्कटॉप पे क्योंकि आपका जो पाथ था यह
चेंज हो गया। अभी आप कहां पर हो? करंट
वर्किंग डायरेक्टरी आपकी क्या है? या करंट
वर्किंग फोल्डर कौन सा आपका? डेस्कटॉप है।
उसके बाद अगर आप डीआईआर करोगे तो डेस्कटॉप
के ऊपर जितने भी फाइल्स आपको देखने को मिल
पा रही है, यह रही एक टेस्ट फोल्डर है। इस
तरीके से आप क्या कर सकते हो? नेविगेट कर
सकते हो। बिल्कुल एग्जैक्टली नेक्स्ट की
तरह अगर आपको प्रीवियस डायरेक्टरी पे जाना
है तो सीडी उसके बाद प्रीवियस डायरेक्टरी
डबल डॉट हिट एंटर। आप प्रीवियस डायरेक्टरी
के ऊपर चले जाओगे या प्रीवियस फोल्डर के
ऊपर। फिर से मैं क्या करता हूं? अभी सीडी
डेस्कटॉप करता हूं। ये रहा सीडी डेस्कटॉप।
अभी हम डेस्कटॉप के अंदर हैं। तो इस तरीके
से आप क्या कर सकते हो? किसी भी फाइल्स या
डायरेक्ट या किसी भी डायरेक्टरी के अंदर
आप क्या कर सकते हो? नेविगेट कर सकते हो।
अपना पाथ बदल सकते हो। बिल्कुल एग्जैक्टली
जैसे आप क्या करते हो? Windows के अंदर
डबल क्लिक करते हो उस फोल्डर के अंदर। फिर
उसके बाद सब फोल्डर फिर उसके बाद फाइल्स
के ऊपर क्लिक करो। उसी प्रकार से यहां भी
आप क्या कर पाते हो? नेविगेट कर पाते हो।
अगर आपको क्या करना है? किसी भी फाइल को
आपको क्या करना है? अभी मैं एक काम करता
हूं। एक फाइल क्रिएट कर देता हूं। टेक्स्ट
फोल्डर के अंदर। यहां पर कोई भी फाइल्स
नहीं है। मैं एक फाइल क्रिएट किया। यहां
पर एक न्यू कोई भी एक
ओके इसका है टेक्स्ट डॉटxt एक फाइल मैंने
किया इट एंटर यहां पर एंटर कर दिया और अभी
मैं आपको कमांड के थ्रू दिखाता हूं
डेस्कटॉप के अंदर हम डीआईआर करते हैं अगर
मुझे जो डीआईआर किया हमने डेस्कटॉप के ऊपर
यहां पर आपको कोई भी फ़ अभी फ़ाइल देख
टेक्स्ट फोल्डर के अंदर जाना पड़ेगा सीडी
टेक्स्ट फ़ोल्डर हिट एंटर देन उसके बाद हम
क्या करेंगे डीआईआर जैसे हम डीआर किया तो
यहां पर आपको टेस्टxt एक फाइल आपको देखने
को मिल रही है ये वाली अगर मुझे इसको मूव
करना है एक प्लेस से दूसरे प्लेस पे मुझे
क्या करना है मूव करना है मूव करने के लिए
मैं कमांड यूज़ करूंगा मूव मूव कमांड उसके
बाद इस फाइल का नेम देन उसके बाद कहां पर
मुझे उसको मूव करना है किसके अंदर टेक्स्ट
वन के अंदर तो मैं क्या करना चाहता हूं
टेक्स्ट वन तो मेरा जो डॉट करंट फोल्डर के
अंदर यह स्लैश और टेक्स्ट वन के ऊपर टेस्ट
वन इस तरीके से हम क्या कर सकते
टेस्ट वन
ओके हिट एंटर देखिए आपने एक फाइल को मूव
कर दिया अगर आप चेक करोगे तो आप नेविगेट
भी कर सकते हो सीडी और टेस्ट वन ओके हिट
एंटर और डीआईआर करके देखिए तो आप इस तरीके
से देख पाओगे इसके अंदर भी एक फाइल है
टेस्टxtrf सेम फाइल है अगर आप इस तरीके से
यहां पर भी चेक करोगे अभी यहां पर देखो
यहां पर वो फाइल नहीं है लेकिन टेस्ट वन
के अंदर जाओगे इस तरीके से आप देख पा रहे
हो ये आपकी सेम फाइल देखो यहां पर इस
तरीके से आपका यूजर एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर
डेस्कटॉप टेक्स्ट फोल्डर टेस्ट वन तो सेम
इधर ही है। यूजर एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर डेस्कटॉप
टेक्स्ट फोल्डर टेस्ट वन। इस तरीके से आप
देख पा रहे हो। तो मैं स्क्रीन को क्लीन
कर लेता हूं। हमने अपनी स्क्रीन को क्लीन
कर लिया। इस तरीके से आप किसी भी एक फाइल
को क्या कर पा रहे हो? मूव कर पा रहे हो
विद दी हेल्प ऑफ ए मूव
कमांड। किसी का कोई डाउट है तो बता दीजिए।
यहां मुझे बताइए सबको स्क्रीन क्लियर
दिखाई दे रही है
सबको स्क्रीन विजिबल
है कोई इशू तो नहीं है ना स्क्रीन के
साथ प्लीज एक बार चैट में बता दीजिए मैं
अभी आपके चैट देख रहा हूं कोई इशू नहीं है
ना
ओके यस ओके तो अभी हम और क्या कर सकते
हैं? किसी फाइल को हमने मूव तो कर दिया।
अगर हम चाहें तो कॉपी भी कर सकते हैं। अब
इस फाइल को मुझे कॉपी करना है। तो कॉपी
करने के लिए मैं क्या करता हूं? कॉपी
कमांड का यूज़ कर सकता हूं। इसमें कॉपी
लिखना पड़ेगा। कॉपी उसके बाद कौन सी फाइल
है? टेस्ट वाली फाइल है। इस फाइल को मैं
कहां पर कॉपी करना चाहता हूं? मैं इसको
कॉपी करना चाहता हूं। फुल पाथ मुझे मेंशन
करना पड़ेगा। किसके अंदर अगर मुझे टेस्ट
टू के अंदर मेंशन करना है तो मैं क्या
करूंगा? उसके लिए मुझे जाना पड़ेगा फुल
पाथ। ठीक है? उसके लिए मुझे क्या जाना
पड़ेगा? फुल पाथ। फुल पाथ क्या रहेगा
मेरा? ये
रहा। सी यूजर एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर और टेस्ट
फोल्डर के अंदर मुझे इसको कॉपी करना है।
तो मैं इसको कॉपी कर सकता हूं।
अभी देखो उसके लिए मुझे क्या करना पड़ेगा?
फुल पाथ मेंशन करने करना पड़ेगा। सी
उसके बाद
यूजर
एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर उसके बाद में रहेगा मेरा
डेस्कटॉप उसके बाद
टेक्स्ट फोल्डर ये रहा इस तरीके से मुझे
क्या करना पड़ेगा इसको मूव कर हम कॉपी कर
सकते हैं हमने सिंपली एंटर किया वन फाइल
कॉपीड अगर हम बैक करके चेक करना चाहे तो
हम चेक कर सकते हैं उसके बाद टेस्ट फोल्डर
के अंदर डीआईआर करेंगे तो आपको टेस्ट
फोल्डर के एक फाइल देखने को मिलेगी टेस्ट
डॉट txt नाम से एक फाइल आपको देखने को मिल
पा रही है। तो इस तरीके से आपने क्या
किया? कॉपी भी कर पाओ। तो आप कॉपी इस
तरीके से कर सकते हो अगर आपको किसी फाइल
को रीनेम करना चाहते हो। फॉर एग्जांपल
मुझे इस फाइल को रीनेम करना है। रीनेम
करने के लिए मैं एक कमांड का यूज़ करूंगा।
उस कमांड का नाम है रेन आर इ एन। उस कमांड
का हम यूज़ करते हैं रेन स्पेस। किस फाइल
को मुझे रीनेम करना है? टेक्स्ट डॉटxt किस
फाइल को मुझे रीनेम करना है इसको?
टेक्स्ट.txt ये रही। टेक्स्टxt वाली फाइल
को मुझे रीनेम करके क्या लिखना है? डेमो
डॉटxt लिखना है मुझे। डेमोxt एंटर हमने
सक्सेसफुली उसको रीनेम कर लिया। dआईआर
देखिए अभी डेमोxt है ये फाइल ना कि टेस्ट
डॉटxt इस तरीके से हम इस कमांड का यूज़ कर
सकते हैं। आर इ एन उसके बाद ओल्ड कमांड
देन फॉललोड बाय जो उसका रीनेम आप करना
चाहते हो जो उसका नया नाम रखना चाहते हो।
इस तरीके से आप क्या कर सकते हो? किसी भी
फाइल को रीनेम कर सकते हो। तो मैंने आपको
सिखा दिया कि कॉपी कैसे करते हैं? मूव
कैसे करते हैं और रिनेम कैसे करते हैं
Windows के अंदर। ओके, समझ में आ गया? अगर
आपको कोई भी फाइल क्या करनी है? क्रिएट
करनी है। सॉरी फोल्डर क्रिएट करना है। अगर
मुझे कोई भी फोल्डर क्रिएट करना है तो मैं
फोल्डर क्रिएट कर सकता हूं। उसके लिए सेम
कमांड होती है आपकी एम के डीआईआर एमके
डीआईआर उसके बाद फोल्डर का नाम। फॉर
एग्जांपल मैं क्या लिख रहा हूं अभी?
डेमो उसके बाद फोल्डर
डेमो फोल्डर वन सिंपली हिट एंटर कर दिया
तो इस तरीके से हमने एक और फोल्डर क्रिएट
कर लिया है। अगर आप डीआईआर करोगे तो आप
देख पाओगे डेमो फोल्डर के नाम से भी एक
फोल्डर आप देख पाओगे। यहां पर देखिए अभी
हम बैक करते हैं। टेस्ट फोल्डर के अंदर
आपको डेमो फोल्डर भी देखने को मिल पा रहा
है। कितना फास्ट काम कर पा रहे हो। अगर आप
ग्राफिकल यूजर इंटरफ़ेस में क्या करते? आप
यहां पर राइट क्लिक करते हैं। राइट क्लिक
करके न्यू करते हैं। देन उसके बाद फोल्डर
क्रिएट करते हैं। यहां पर सिंपली आप एक
कमांड की हेल्प से ये सारे काम कर पा रहे
हो। तो इस तरीके से आप एम के डी आई आर एम
के डी आई आर कमांड की हेल्प से किसी भी
फाइल को क्या कर सकते हो? किसी भी फोल्डर
को क्रिएट कर सकते हो। फाइल नहीं है। अभी
मैंने आपको फोल्डर बताए हैं। अगर इस
फोल्डर को डिलीट करना है तो मैं डिलीट
कैसे कर सकता हूं? उसके लिए एक मेरी कमांड
होती है डेल कमांड। उसके लिए मेरी कमांड
होती है डेल। उसके बाद मेरा क्या है?
डेमो।
डेमो नेम डेमो फोल्डर वन और हिट एंटर जैसे
हमने ओके यह बोल रहा है कि आर यू श्योर यस
आई आर श्योर कि मैं इस फोल्डर को क्या
करना चाहता हूं डिलीट करना चाहता हूं तो
इस फोल्डर को हमने क्या कर लिया डिलीट कर
दिया अगर हम इसको चेक करेंगे डीआई कमांड
की हेल्प से तो आप देखोगे यहां पर ओके आर
यू सो यस नॉट शोर कि मैं अभी डिलीट किया
डेल वन
तो इस फोल्डर को डिलीट क्यों नहीं हुआ यह
अभी तक?
ओके ओके ओके ओके ये फाइल को डिलीट करने के
लिए आई एम सॉरी फॉर दैट बाय मिस्टेक ये
फोल्डर को डिलीट करने के लिए आर एमडीआईआर
करेंगे। रिमूव डायरेक्टरी उसके बाद किसका
हम यूज़ करने वाले हैं? डेमो
डेमो फोल्डर हिट एंटर ये रहा। आर एमडीआईआर
की हेल्प से आप क्या कर सकते हैं? किसी भी
फोल्डर को रिमूव कर सकते हो और आर एम
कमांड की हेल्प से रिमूव डेल कमांड की
हेल्प से किसी भी फाइल को आप डिलीट कर
सकते हो। डेमोxt फाइल को आप चाहो तो डिलीट
कर सकते हो। जैसे कि हमने डल किया। उसके
बाद टेक्स्ट वन के अंदर वो आपकी फाइल थी।
तो टेक्स्ट वन के अंदर आपकी फाइल का नाम
क्या था? टेस्टxt इसको मैं डिलीट करना
चाहता हूं। सिंपली हिट किया और यह फाइल
डिलीट हो गई। अगर आप चेक करोगे तब इस
तरीके से टेस्ट वन के अंदर वो फाइल नहीं
है। तो आर एमडीआईआर कमांड जो है उससे आप
क्या कर सकते हो? ये रहा इस कमांड की
हेल्प से क्या कर सकते हो आप? किसी भी
फोल्डर को डिलीट कर सकते हो और डिलीट
कमांड की हेल्प से आप किसी भी फाइल को
डिलीट कर सकते हो। ओके? उसके बाद हम क्या
कर सकते हैं? अगर मुझे किसी भी फाइल की
परमिशंस को देखना है। जैसे आप लinक्स में
देखते हो उस तरीके से इसमें भी आप फाइल की
परमिशंस को देख सकते हो। तो उसके फाइल की
परमिशन को देखने के लिए हम कमांड कौन सी
यूज़ करते हैं? एक कमांड होती है
आपकी आईकल आई सी एल एस आई के्स ओके उसके
बाद डेमोxt डेमो डॉटxt हिट एंटर अभी देखिए
यहां पर आई डेमोxt इज़ नॉट रिकॉग्नाइज़्ड
इंटरनल एक्सटर्नल कमांड एंड ऑपरेशन बैच
फाइल मे बी एंड आई एल्स ओके ओके
आई सी एल सी आई सी एल सी एलएस ओके यह है
वो
कमांड आई सी एल सीएलएस
ओके ओ हो आई एम सॉरी फॉर दैट मैं कमांड की
थोड़ी गड़बड़ कर रहा हूं आई एम क्रॉस चेक
आई सीए
सीएलएस सीएलएस उसके बाद यह कमांड है देन
डेमो डॉटxt हिट एंटर आप देख पाओगे कि इस
जो डायरेक्ट ये आपकी फाइल है डेमोxt है यह
क्या बोल रहे
हो सर वीडियो रुक-रुक के आ रही है
नहीं वीडियो कंटीन्यूअसली
है अपना कनेक्शन चेक करो एक बार जगत गुरु
जी मेरी वीडियो रुक के नहीं आ रही एक बार
कनेक्शन चेक करो आप
ओके कनेक्शन चेक चेक करो आपका क्योंकि
वीडियो में कोई प्रॉब्लम नहीं है।
ओके। तो अभी आपको मैंने बताया कि अगर आपको
किसी भी फाइल की परमिशंस देखनी है तो उसके
ऊपर देख सकते हो कि किस-किस को परमिशंस
हैं। एंटी अथॉरिटी सिस्टम्स को परमिशंस
है। बिल्ट इन एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर्स को परमिशंस
है और जो एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर्स है इन तीनों को
ही परमिशंस हैं इस फाइल के ऊपर और किसी
यूज़र्स को इसके ऊपर कोई भी परमिशंस नहीं
है। आप चाहे तो किसी भी यूज़र्स या किसी
भी किसी भी यूज़र्स को क्या कर सकते हो?
परमिशंस देख दे सकते हो। लेकिन मैं अभी
आपको परमिशंस मैनेज करना नहीं सिखाऊंगा
जस्ट क्योंकि एज ए पेंटेस्टर आपको परमिशन
देखनी है। उसके बाद उनके हिसाब से आपको
रिएक्ट करना है।
ओके? समझ में आ गया? देखो एफ का मतलब होता
है फुल परमिशंस। ठीक है? एफ का मतलब होता
है आपको फुल परमिशंस होती हैं। एफ का मतलब
फुल परमिशंस है। देखो यहां पर एफ का मतलब
फुल परमिशंस है। ये जो तीनों यूज़र्स हैं
इनको क्या है? आपकी फुल परमिशंस। अगर आपको
एम देखने को मिलती है तो सिर्फ आप मॉडिफाई
कर सकते हो। अगर आपको आर और एक्स देखने को
मिलती है तो रीड एंड एग्जीक्यूट अगर आपको
ओनली आर देखने को मिल मिल पा रही है तो
ओनली रीड और डब्ल्यू मतलब राइट ओके इस
तरीके से आप देख सकते
हो अभी मुझे एक और चीज है नया कांसेप्ट है
इसको मैं क्लियर कर दूं यहां तक सबको
क्लियर है किसी को कोई डाउट है तो मुझसे
पूछ सकता है हम नेक्स्ट कमांड पर जा रहे
हैं फिर यहां तक किसी को कोई डाउट है किसी
को कुछ पूछना है
यस अभी मैं एडमिन प्रिलिजेस के आपको सिखा
रहा हूं कि एडमिन प्रिलजेस के साथ आप
कौन-कौन सी कमांड रन कर सकते हो। ओके।
ओके अगर आपका डे वन है तो क्लास को
कंटिन्यू कीजिए और आपको प्रीवियस क्लास को
रिकवर करना है।
ओनली 36 हुआ है। 37 क्लास हो तो आप आसानी
से रिकवर कर सकते हो। तो मैं अभी कंटिन्यू
करने वाला हूं। अगर आपको किसी भी फाइल को
हाइड करना है या किसी भी फोल्डर को हाइड
करना है तो आप कैसे कर सकते हो वो मैं
आपको सिखाता हूं। फॉर एग्जांपल टेक्स्ट
फोर को हमें होल्डर करना है। अभी मैं इसको
क्या करता हूं? हाइड करना है या उसके अंदर
एक फाइल है। ये फाइल ही है। अगर एलएस करते
हैं। देखो ओ सॉरी एलएस नहीं है। डीआईआर
करते हैं। डीआईआर किया। यहां पर आपको
टेस्ट फोल्डर दिख रहा है। उसके बाद आप एक
काम करते हैं। टेस्ट फोल्डर के अंदर जाते
हैं। फिर से आई एम सॉरी कोड ये रहा और डी
आई आर
डेमोxt फाइल है। अगर मुझे इसको हाइड करना
है। ओके? क्योंकि फॉर एग्जांपल ये मेरी
एक्स एक्सप्लइट की फाइल है। अगर मैं इसको
हाइड करना चाहता हूं। तो हाइड करने के लिए
मैं क्या करूंगा ताकि आप किसी भी यूज़र्स
को देख ना पाए। इसकी खासियत ये है कि अगर
आप नॉर्मली अगर किसी फाइल को हाइड करते
कैसे करोगे? देखो राइट क्लिक किया। यहां
पर प्रॉपर्टीज पे जाओगे। देन रिहडन फाइल
करोगे, अप्लाई करोगे। इस तरीके से करते
थे। उसके बाद इसको अनहाइड कर सकते हैं। आप
देख सकते हो। लेकिन अगर आपने कमांड लाइन
से किसी भी फाइल को हाइड किया है तो आप
ऐसे भी हाइड और अनहाइड के हिसाब से भी
उसको नहीं देख सकते। ओके? तो अभी हम क्या
करेंगे? अभी इसको यूज़ करेंगे। उसके लिए एक
कमांड होती है आपकी एट्रिब। ए डबल टी आर
आई बी। एक कमांड होती है आपकी एट्रिब प्लस
में प्लस सिंबल यूज़ करते हैं। एच का मतलब
हाइड। उसके बाद फाइल का नेम एच का मतलब
हाइड ओके उसके बाद क्या कर सकते हो फाइल
का नेम डेमोxt डेमो डॉटxt और हमने हिट
एंटर किया ये फाइल क्या हो जाएगी आपकी
हाइड हो जाएगी
ओके ये रहा ये फाइल आपकी हाइड हो जाएगी
अगर आप इसको चाहोगे तो देखिए डीआईआर ये
फाइल आपको नहीं दिख देख पा रहे आप आगे आप
क्या करोगे यहां पर जाओगे और यह मेरी
डेस्कटॉप है फॉर एग्जांपल अभी हम क्या
करते
मिनिमाइज और यह मेरा टेस्ट फोल्डर है।
यहां पर वह फाइल है नहीं इसमें देख देखना
चाहूं तो गिव एक्सेस ओके प्रॉपर्टीज और हम
क्या शेयरिंग सिक्योरिटी ओके वर्जन
कस्टमाइज एंड चूज फाइल और चाहे हम यहां पर
एक ऑप्शन होता है आई एम नॉट एबल टू सी भी
आपको फाइल किसी भी तरीके से नहीं देख
पाएगी अगर आप ओनली कमांड से ही इसको क्या
कर सकते हो हाइड और अनहाइड कर सकते हो अगर
मुझे इसको अनहाइड करना है इस फाइल को मुझे
अगर अनहाइड करना है तो ओनली मैं इसको
अनहाइड की परमिशन दे सकता हूं। कैसे? आप
क्या करोगे? एट्रिब्यूट हफन माइनस एच
करोगे। हफन नहीं हफन करोगे। प्लस एच किया
तो आपने हाइड कर दिया। इसी फाइल को आपने
क्या किया? माइनस किया। अब ये फाइल आप देख
पाओगे। देखिए अभी ये फाइल आप क्या कर
पाओगे? देख पाओगे। डेमो.xt फिर से आपके
सामने आ गया। अगर इसी फाइल पे मुझे परमिशन
को कंट्रोल करना है। ओनली मैं चाहता हूं
इसको ओनली रीड परमिशंस हो। इसके ऊपर कोई
भी राइट परमिशंस नहीं हो। तो कैसे दे सकता
हूं इसको मैं? ए्रिप इस फाइल को एड्रिप और
हफन आर लिखूंगा मैं इसको ओनली हफन आर लिखा
प्लस आर प्लस लिखूंगा मैं प्लस कमांड
मेंशन करूंगा हिट एंटर ये देखिए अभी इस
फाइल के ऊपर ओनली रीड परमिशंस रहेंगी राइट
परमिशंस नहीं बचेंग अगर हम चाहे तो एक बार
चेक कर सकते हैं उससे एक कमांड थी
हमारी ये रहा ये रहा ये रहा डेमोxt अभी
इनके लिए तो है ये बट इस पर्टिकुलर फाइल
पे रेड परमिशंस है ओके तो अभी cls इनके
लिए रहेगी क्योंकि इन्होंने इनको डिजाइन
किया ये इस पर्टिकुलर फाइल के ऊपर परमिशंस
है आपकी प्रिवेंट एक्सेस है। ओ देन उसके
बाद आप क्या कर सकते हो? किसी भी फोल्डर
को भी क्या कर सकते हो? आप हाइड कर सकते
हो। आप किसी भी फोल्डर को भी हाइड कर सकते
हो। कैसे कर सकते हो? अगर फोल्डर को हाइड
करना है तो एट्रिब ये रहा। एट्रिब +
h + h और टेस्ट फोर को मैं हाइड करता हूं।
टेस्ट टेस्ट फोर को मैं क्या करता हूं?
टेस्ट वन नहीं टेस्ट फोर को हाइड करता
हूं। हिट एंटर। यह देखिए इस फोल्डर को
हमने हाइड कर दिया। अगर मैं डीआई आर
करूंगा तो आपको टेस्ट फोर्थ नाम का फोल्डर
देखने को नहीं मिलेगा। सेम लाइक डेमोxt
फाइल। अब इसको अनहाइड करना है तो अनहाइड
करने के लिए हम क्या
करेंगे? ये रहा माइनस माइनस सिंबल का हम
यूज़ करने वाले हैं। तो ये आपकी अभी तक की
जितनी भी कमांड्स मैंने आपको बताई है,
सारी की सारी क्या है? बेसिक कमांड्स थी।
ओके? ये आपकी सारी की सारी क्या थी? बेसिक
कमांड थी। अभी मैं आपको सिखाता हूं
कि
चलो अगर आपको यह देखना है कि मेरी जो मशीन
है इसके अंदर बिट लॉocker काम कर रहा है
नहीं कर रहा है। बिट लॉocker स्टेटस देखना
चाहता हूं। तो बिट लॉक का स्टेटस देखने के
लिए कमांड होती है मैनेज एम ए एन ए एम ए
एन ए जी ई मैनेज हफन बी डी ई उसके बाद हफन
स्टेटस ए टी यू एस हफन स्टेटस हफन स्टेटस
यस हिट एंटर देखिए इज़ नॉट रिकॉग्नाइज्ड एट
इंटरनल एक्सटर्नल कमांड कुछ तो कर किया
मैंने एम ए एन जी हफन पी डी
ई आई थिंक इस कमांड में मैंने कुछ लिखने
में प्रॉब्लम क्रिएट की है या इस
पर्टिकुलर उसके लिए काम नहीं कर
रही।
हम एक कमांड सही है। इट्स ओके। अभी इसमें
काम नहीं कर रही। लेकिन मेरी मशीन के लिए
काम किया था। अगर मैं देखना चाहूं तो
सीएमडी और इसी कमांड को मैं सॉरी सीएमडी
नहीं मैं इसमें भी रन एज एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर
करता हूं। अगर कमांड प्र्प्ट को रन एन
एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर ओके और अभी
मैं ये रहा मैनेज बी डीई उसके बाद मैं
क्या करता हूं उसके बाद मैं मैनेज
स्टेटस
स्टेटस ये देखिए इसने बताया कि कौन सा
फुल्ली डिक्रिप्टेड है फुल्ली इंक्रिप्टेड
यह इंफॉर्मेशन आपको देखने को मिलेगी।
देखिए साइज क्या है? बिट लॉockकर वर्जन
आपको शो नहीं कर रहा। अभी कन्वर्जन स्टेटस
डिक्रिप्टेड है और प्रोटेक्शन स्टेटस ऑफ
है। उसके बाद लॉक स्टेटस अनलॉक्ड है। देन
उसके बाद डी वॉल्यूम का क्या साइज है
मेरा। उसके बाद फुल्ली डिक्रिप्टेड है।
देन परसेंटेज इंक्रिप्टेड अह ज़ीरो है।
क्योंकि मैंने इसको ऑफ किया हुआ है।
प्रोटेक्शन स्टेटस प्रोटेक्शन ऑफ है।
ऑटोमेटिक अनलॉक डिसेबल्ड है। तो इस तरीके
से आप क्या कर सकते हो कि आपका जो बिट
लॉकर्स है उसकी भी इंफॉर्मेशनेशन चेक कर
सकते हो कि आपका जो हार्ड ड्राइव डाटा
होगा उसको इंक्रिप्ट किया गया है या नहीं
किया गया है। उसके अलावा आप क्या कर सकते
हो? अगर मुझे इसका यह देखना है कि वर्जन
क्या है? अभी अभी तक दो हमने जस्ट ओनली
बेसिक कमांड देखी है। अभी मैं देखना चाहता
हूं कि जो मेरी मशीन है उस मशीन का वर्जन
क्या है? उस वर्जन स्पेसिफिक इनेशन देखना
चाहता हूं। उसके लिए एक कमांड होती है
वीईआर। वीआर जैसे हमने किया है तो ये है
Microsoft Windows उसका वर्जन Windows
10.0 उसका ये बिल्ट नंबर के साथ आपको शो
कर रहा है। अगर आप चाहो तो पूरी डिटेल्ड
इनेशन देख सकते हो। एक कमांड होती है
सिस्टम इनफो में सिस्टम इनफो एक कमांड
होती है। हिट एंटर करोगे तो यहां पर पूरे
सिस्टम की इंफॉर्मेशन आपके सामने आ जाएगी।
इवन उसकी फिजिकल रैेम है क्या है? देखिए
यहां पर देख सकते हो। ये रहा होस्ट नेम
क्या है उसका? ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम Microsoft
Windows सर्वर 2019 डाटा सेंटर ऑपरेटिंग
सिस्टम वर्जन क्या है? 10 पॉइंट इसका यह
वर्जन है।
10.0.176 बिल्ट नंबर इसका यह है।
मैन्युफैक्चर Microsoft है। कॉन्फ़िगरेशन
स्टैंड अलोन सर्वर है। ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम
बिल टाइप मल्टी प्रोसेसर फ्री है। रजिस्टर
ओनर Windows यूजर है। प्रोडक्ट आईडी यह
है। उसके बाद कब इसको इंस्टॉल किया गया
था? बूट टाइम इसका अभी मैन्युफैक्चरर
vएमवेयर पे काम कर रहा है। उसके बाद इसके
कितने अंदर प्रोसेसर इंस्टॉल किए गए हैं?
उसकी डिटेल्स बायoस वीएमवेयर का यूज़ किया
जा रहा है। देन ये रहा सिस्टम डायरेक्टरी
इसकी सिस्टम 32 है। Windows डायरेक्टरी C
Windows 32 कौन से वर्जन यूज़ किया जा रहा
है? इंग्लिश वर्जन टाइम ज़ोन कौन सा है?
उसके बाद फिजिकल मेमोरी 4GB है। अवेलेबल
मेमोरी कितनी है?
2780 वर्चुअल मेमोरी को शो किया जा रहा
है। तो यह सारी इंफॉर्मेशन उसके बाद हॉट
फिक्सेस हमने इसको अपडेट किया है। तो
कितनी बार कौन-कौन से अपडेट हमने अभी तक
किए हुए हैं। तो इस नंबर के बेस पे ही
बहुत सारी इंफॉर्मेशन निकल जाती है
क्योंकि जो ये मशीन है जो सर्वर है यह
लेटेस्ट अपडेट किया गया है या नहीं किया
गया है। नेटवर्क कार्ड की इनेशन और हाइपर
वी डिटेक्टेड है, नॉट डिटेक्टेड है। दे आर
लॉट ऑफ इनेशन रिलेटेड टू द सिस्टम्स। ये
आपको देखने को मिले। अगर आप होस्ट नेम
देखना चाहते हो ओनली होस्ट नेम की भी
कमांड होती है। होस्ट नेम ये हिट एंटर तो
ये आप इसका होस्ट नेम है। विन सो करके ये
इसका होस्ट नेम है। अगर आप देखना चाहते हो
कि इसके अंदर जितने भी ड्राइवर्स हैं उनके
जो मॉड्यूल्स हैं उनका टाइप है फुल पाथ के
साथ इनेशन देखना चाहते हो तो वो भी आप देख
सकते हो। कैसे एक कमांड होती है आपकी
ड्राइवर ड्राइवर क्यूरी क यू ई आर वाई ये
रहा। ड्राइवर क्यूरी फिट एंटर। जैसे आपने
किया देखिए यहां पर आपको बहुत सारी इनेशन
देखने को मिलेगी। ये रहा ड्राइवर क्यूरी
बहुत सारी डिटेल्ड इनेशन अगर हम सबसे ऊपर
चलते हैं तो बहुत डिटेल्ड इनेशन यहां पर
ये रहा देखिए कौन-कौन से ड्राइवर्स इसके
अंदर इंस्टॉल्ड हैं? देखिए ये रहा सबसे
पहले मॉड्यूल नेम क्या है? डिस्प्ले नाम
क्या रहेगा? उसका ड्राइवर किस टाइप का है?
उसकी लिंक और डेट देखिए। यह सारे इसके
ड्राइवर्स हैं। एएफडी इसके अंदर जो भी
ड्राइवर्स इंस्टॉल है उनकी इंफॉर्मेशन
इसके अंदर अवेलेबल है। फाइल सिस्टम कर्नल
ड्राइवर है, फाइल सिस्टम ड्राइवर है। ऑल
आर द इनेशन रिलेटेड टू द ड्राइवर्स की
आपको देखने को मिल रहा है। अगर आप चाहो तो
हफन वी का यूज़ करके और भी ज्यादा डिटेल्स
इनेशन देख सकते हो। इसकी कैसे हम चलते हैं
अभी ये
रहा। अभी ये रहा। अगर मैं इसको हफन वी यूज़
करता हूं इसके साथ तो मैं देख सकता हूं।
ये रहा। यह डिटेल्स और भी डिटेल्ड
इंफॉर्मेशन है। डिसेबल्ड है, स्टॉप्ड है।
उसके बाद उसका पाथ भी है। यहां पर देखो अब
ये क्या है कि काफी अजीब दिख रहा होगा
क्योंकि साइज छोटा है। यहां देखोगे देखो
ड्राइवर का नेम उसका डिस्प्ले नेम उसके
बाद कर्नल का ड्राइवर है। मैनुअल है। अभी
उसके स्टॉप कंडीशन में है। उसके बाद बहुत
सारी अदर इनेशन है उसकी। उसका फुल पाथ यह
कहां पर इंस्टॉल्ड है आपका? Windows
सिस्टम 32 ड्राइवर्स है। डब्ल्यू डी आर एफ
डी सिस ये ड्राइवर उसका कुछ साइज है ये तो
इस तरीके से आप देख पा रहे हो कि बहुत
ज्यादा डिटेल्ड इनेशन आपको शो कर पा रहे
हो अगर आप देखना चाहते हो डेट और टाइम भी
आप चेंज कर सकते हो अपनी मशीन के अंदर
कैसे कर सकते हो तो उसके लिए कमांड होती
है डेट हिट एंटर जैसे एंटर करोगे तो आपको
करंट डेट देखने को मिल जाएगी ट्यूसडे 15
एंड 25 अगर आप चाहो तो इसको चेंज कर सकते
हो यहीं पर आप एक नई डेट मेंशन कर सकते हो
लेकिन मैं इसको चेंज नहीं करना चाहता तो
इसलिए हिट एंटर आप टाइम की इनेशन भी देख
सकते हो हिट एंटर किया तो ये आपका टाइमिंग
इनफॉर्म है। करंट टाइम मेरा क्या है? 721
इसके हिसाब से मशीन के हिसाब से उसके बाद
यह इतनी सेकंड हुई इतनी मिली सेकंड। आप
चाहो तो इस टाइम को भी चेंज कर सकते हो।
जैसे फॉर एग्जांपल 721 था तो मैं अभी क्या
कर सकता
हूं?
07 मैंने क्या किया? 07 52 कर दिया। हिट
एंटर किया। देखो अभी जो मैं टाइम होगा
यहां पे देखिए ये आपको देखने को मिल रहा
है 52। ओके? ये 52 आ गया हमारा। समझ में आ
गया? तो इस तरीके से आप टाइम भी चेंज कर
सकते हो यहां पर। अभी यहां तक की तो मैं
जो अभी कमांड बताई बिल्कुल ही नॉर्मल
कमांड थी। अभी आप यह देख सकते हो कैसे
टास्क कमांड लाइन की हेल्प से कैसे टास्क
को मैनेज किया जाए। टास्क का मतलब क्या
होता है? जैसे आप राइट क्लिक करते हो तो
यहां पर टास्क मैनेजर देखते हो। टास्क
मैनेजर के अंदर बहुत सारी चीजें आपको
देखने को मिलती है। जैसे कि अभी ये क्या
है? सर्वर है, सर्वर मैनेजर है, Windows
प्रोसेसर्स है। यहां पर उस तरीके का आपको
देखने को नहीं मिल रहा है जितना जिस तरीके
आपको देखना यह रहा है। हियर परफॉर्मेंस दे
आर लॉट ऑफ़ टास्क। ये सारे के सारे टास्क
हैं। तो ये सारी चीजें आप भी देख सकते हो
कहां पर?
अपनी कमांड लाइन के अंदर। इसके अंदर
कौन-कौन सी सर्विज है? तो ये सारी इनेशन
देख सकते हो। कैसे देख सकते हो? मैं आपको
एक कमांड बताता हूं। एक कमांड होती है
टास्क लिस्ट। टास्क लिस्ट नाम से कमांड
होती है। टास्क लिस्ट नाम से कमांड होती
है। और जैसे हम हिट एंटर करेंगे यह देखिए
यह सारे जितने भी टास्क हैं अभी ये क्या
है कि जिस टाइम पे आपने कमांड को रन किया
जितने भी टास्क जितनी भी प्रोसेससेस रन कर
रही थी सारी की इनेशन इसने यहां पर शो कर
दी। देखिए svc होस्ट.exc सबको समझ में आ
रहा है। इसकी प्रोसेस आईडी है। सर्विज है।
उसके बाद यह रहा सेशन ज़ीरो कौन से सेशन
में रन करें? आपको बताया था मैंने सेशन
जीरो में कौन सी सर्विस प्रोसेससेस काम
करती हैं और सेशन वन में कौन सी
प्रोसेससेस काम करती हैं? कितनी मेमोरी को
यूज़ कर रही है। ओके ये देखिए इतनी मेमोरी
को यूज़ किया जा रहा है। अगर आप चाहो तो और
भी डिटेल्ड इनेशन देख सकते हो। टास्क
लिस्ट हफन ये रहा फॉरवर्ड स्लैश और वी को
यूज़ करके आप देख सकते हो।
ओके फॉरवर्ड स्लश और वी यूज़ कर सकते हो।
हिट एंटर जैसे आप एंटर करोगे यह काफी
डिटेल्स में इंफॉर्मेशन है। प्रोसेस का
नाम उसकी पीआईडी क्या है? सर्विज है उसके
उसके पास कौन-कौन सी सर्विज हैं अननोन? अब
यह क्या है? किस यूजर ने उसको रन किया है?
किस यूजर ने उसको रन किया है? किस जैसे कि
कौन सा इसको एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर के द्वारा रन
किया है। इसको नेटवर्क सर्विस के द्वारा
इसको एंटी अथॉरिटी सिस्टम के द्वारा इसको
नॉर्मल एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर के द्वारा सिस्टम
के द्वारा एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर
एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर। आप इस तरीके से इसको फ़्टर
आउट भी कर सकते हो। तो जब आप जैसे ही आप
पेन टेस्टिंग में आगे बढ़ोगे, जैसे ही आप
एडवांस प्रोफेशनल लेवल पे जाओगे, तब इनको
क्या है? अभी मैं आपको इतनी सारी कमांड
बताऊंगा, तो आप कंफ्यूज हो जाओगे। मैं
जस्ट आपको बता रहा हूं कि टास्क देखने के
लिए टास्क लिस्ट कमांड होती है। इसके भी
बहुत सारे ऑप्शंस होते हैं। कैसे? टास्क
लिस्ट। उसके बाद आप क्या कर सकते हो?
फॉरवर्ड स्लश क्वेश्चन मार्क। देखिए ये
इसकी हेल्प फाइल है कि ये इतनी डिटेल्स
इसकी हेल्प फाइल है कि इतने सारे ऑप्शंस
इसके साथ आप यूज़ कर सकते हो टास्क लिस्ट
के साथ। देखिए सिस्टम, यूजरनेम, पासवर्ड
देखिए, दिस टू डिस्प्ले लिस्ट ऑफ करेंटली
रनिंग प्रोसेससेस ऑन आइदर ए लोकल और रिमोट
मशीन। आप रिमोट मशीन पे भी एक्सेस ले तब
भी आप रन कर सकते हो। जैसे कि स्पेसिफाई द
रिमोट सिस्टम टू कनेक्ट टू डोमेन के ऊपर
भी पर्टिकुलर यूजर से रिलेटेड भी टास्क
देख सकते हो। उसके यूजरनेम पासवर्ड
प्रोवाइड करके लिस्ट ऑल टास्क करेंटली
यूजिंग द गिवन एग्जीक्यूशन डीएलएल के
अकॉर्डिंग में चेक कर सकते हो।
हर एक प्रोसेस के अकॉर्डिंग आप सर्विज
देखना चाहते हो ओनली तो यह भी कर सकते हो
आप कैसे मैं आपको दिखाता हूं देखो यह रहा
अभी एसवीसी एसवीसी ओनली सर्विस देखो हिट
एंटर इस ये जो प्रोसेस है यह इसकी प्रोसेस
आईडी है और यह देखिए कौन-कौन सी सर्विज
अपने साथ रन कर रही है ये कौन-कौन सी
सर्विज यह अपने साथ रन कर रही है फॉर
एग्जांपल मैंने एक नोटपड को मैंने रन किया
नोटपड यह टेंडर कर गया। यह नोटपड ओपन हो
गया। इसकी एक प्रोसेस ओपन होगी यहां पर।
ठीक है? इसको मैं मिनिमाइज करता हूं। अभी
नोटपैड की एक सर्विस रन कर रही है।
प्रोसेस रन कर रही है। अब मैं इसको देखता
हूं। ये हां टास्क लिस्ट में ही देख लेते
हैं नॉर्मल। चलो इधर भी देख लेंगे। तो
आपको नोटपैड की कहीं पर देखने को मिलेगी।
नोटपैड नोटपैड ये रही। इसकी पीआईडी क्या
है?
588। अगर मुझे इसको किल करना है तो मैं
इसको यहां से भी क्या कर सकता हूं? किल कर
सकता हूं। यहां से भी किल कर सकता हूं।
कैसे? उसके लिए एक कमांड होती है आपकी
टास्क किल कमांड। टास्क किल कमांड होती
है। उसके बाद आप क्या कर सकते हो? उसकी
पीआईडी मेंशन करते हैं। फॉर स्लश पीआईडी
उसके बाद इसकी पीआईडी क्या है मेरी?
58 हिट एंटर। जैसे हमने एंटर किया सेंड
टर्मिनेशन सिग्नल टू द प्रोसेस विद
पीआईडी। और यह क्लोज भी हो गया। अगर फिर
से आप रन करोगे यह रहा। अभी आपको
यह सर्विज देखने को नहीं मिलेगी। ओके? आप
चाहो तो प्रोसेस नेम के हिसाब से भी जो है
यहां पर जो इमेज आपको देखने को मिल रही
है। यह आपका क्या है? टास्क नेम होता है।
अगर आप ऊपर देखोगे इमेज नेम में क्या है?
वहां पर जो आप ग्राफिकल यूजर इंटरफ़ेस पे
देखने को मिलता है। वहां पर क्या प्रोसेस
नेम मिलता है। लेकिन सीएलआई में इमेज नेम
रहता है। तो आप इमेज नेम देकर भी किसी भी
सर्विज को क्या कर सकते हो या किसी भी
प्रोसेस को क्या कर सकते हो? क्लोज कर
सकते हो। तो यहां तक सबको क्लियर है? यहां
तक सबको क्लियर
है? कौन से अकाउंट की बात कर रहे हो? लोकल
सिस्टम अकाउंट का एक्सेस आपको पैन
टेस्टिंग के टाइम पर ही मिलते हैं। वैसे
आप स्विच नहीं कर पाओगे। शुभम अब जब आप पन
टेस्टिंग करोगे, प्रिविलेज एस्केलेशन
करोगे, कई बार आपको एंटी अथॉरिटी भी
मिलेगा, कई बार आपको सिस्टम अकाउंट
मिलेगा। तब उस टाइम पर भी यह सारे काम कर
सकते हो आप रन करके। लेकिन वहां पर आपको
क्या प्रिविलजेस मिलते हैं तब आपको पता
चलेगा। इसको बड़ा नहीं कर सकता यार मैं।
इसको बड़ा नहीं कर
सकता। मेरे पास यही साइज रहेगा इसका
क्योंकि आप एक काम कर सकते हो। आपके पास
एक ऑप्शन है। आप अपने YouTube को ज़ूम कर
सकते हो। अगर आप मोबाइल से हो तो आप ज़ूम
कर सकते
हो। क्योंकि यह मैं रिमोट कनेक्शन है
सर्वर के साथ। मैं इसके इसको ज़ूम नहीं कर
सकता। यह मेरे पास डिसएडवांटेज।
अगर यह मुझे रिकॉर्डिंग क्रिएट की हुई थी।
अगर मैं इसको रिकॉर्ड करता तो मैं जूम
करके दिखा सकता था। बट यह अभी मैं इसको
कोशिश भी करूं तो तब भी इससे ज्यादा साइज
नहीं आता इसका। बस इतना ही आता है
यह। इससे ज्यादा साइज आता ही नहीं है।
देखो क्रिएट भी नहीं हो
रहा। मैं इसका कुछ नहीं कर सकता क्योंकि
रिमोट कनेक्शन मेरा क्रिएट इतना हो रहा
है। अगर मैं इसको देखता हूं एक मिनट। 200
ओके गुड हो गया हो गया हो
गया अभी सही
है अभी हो गया अपना चलो
अभी क्या ऐसे हमने करना पड़ेगा यह ज़ूम तो
हम कर लेंगे इसको देखो अभी प्रॉब्लम यह है
हमारे
पास रोज रोहन आपको किसी को फोर्स नहीं कर
सकते कांटेक्ट नंबर देने के
लिए। 150 कर दें चलो आपका काम चल रहा है
तो अच्छा रहेगा। फिर इसको हम इधर रखते
हैं। ठीक है? इसको
[संगीत]
हम शेयरस करता हूं एक बार मैं इसको।
क्लियर क्लीन स्क्रीन। ओके। शायद आपको सही
दिखाई दे रहा
होगा। देयर आर ओनली 18 स्टूडेंट। ओके गुड।
अच्छी बात है भाई। इतना ही आओगे तो मैं भी
सेशन ऐसे ही लूंगा। तो यहां तक अगर आपका
क्लियर है तो अभी मैं आपको बताऊं कि
सर्विज कैसे देख सकते हो। अगर मेरे सिस्टम
के अंदर कितनी सर्विज रन कर रही हैं वो
मैं देखना चाहता हूं तो देख सकता हूं।
देखिए उसके लिए कमांड होती है एससी एससी
क्यूरी एससी क्यूरी हिट एंटर अब ये सर्विज
की इंफॉर्मेशन आपके सामने आ रही है देखो
ये आपकी सर्विज की इनेशन यहां पे जैसे कि
ये रहा सर्विस का नेम ये रहा डिस्प्ले नेम
का विंडोज मैनेजमेंट wmआई सर्विस है टाइप
किस टाइप के विन 32 है करेंटली स्टेटस
क्या है आपका रनिंग है ये उसके बाद और भी
सारी इंफॉर्मेशन जैसे कि यह सारी सर्विस
है wms विंड Windows लाइसेंसिंग मॉनिटरिंग
सर्विस है। उसके
बाद सीपीू यूजर सर्विज है। आप इस तरीके से
क्या है कि सारी की सारी सर्विज हैं उनको
देख सकते हो। अगर आप चाहो तो किसी
पर्टिकुलर सर्विस को भी देख सकते हो। जैसे
फॉर एग्जांपल मैं प्रिंट स्कूलर की सर्विस
देखना चाहता हूं तो वो कैसे देखूंगा?
सर्विस क्यूरी या स्पूलर सर्विस क्यूरी
स्पूलर एक प्रिंट स्पूलर होती है। यह
देखो स्पूलर प्रिंट स्पूलर टाइप है विन 32
ऑन प्रोसेस इंटरेक्टिव प्रोसेस रनिंग है।
यह भी एक सर्विज है। तो इस तरीके से आप
क्या कर सकते हो? सारी सर्विज की इनेशन
देख सकते हो। किसी भी सर्विस को आप स्टॉप
भी कर सकते हो, स्टार्ट भी कर सकते हो।
फॉर एग्जांपल मैं इस सर्विस को स्टार्ट भी
कर सकता हूं। एससी स्टॉप एससी स्टॉप और
स्कूलर इस सर्विस को मैं चाहूं तो स्टॉप
कर सकता हूं। पर हमने क्या किया? इस
सर्विस को स्टॉप कर दिया। देखो स्टॉप
पेंडिंग इस सर्विस को आप क्या कर सकते हो?
स्टार्ट भी कर सकते हो। कॉन्फ़िगर भी कर
सकते हो इस कमांड की हेल्प से। बट हम इसको
कॉन्फ़िगर नहीं सर्विसेस उसके बाद स्टार्ट।
उसके बाद
स्कूलर हिट एंटर। तो हम इस सर्विस को क्या
किया? हमने इसको स्टार्ट भी कर दिया। अभी
आप देखोगे यहां पर स्टार्ट पेंडिंग। अभी
पेंडिंग है। इट विल टेक टाइम मे बी
स्टार्ट होने में क्यूरी। यह देखिए अभी
सर्विस आपकी क्या है? रनिंग कंडीशन में
है। अगर आप चाहो तो एक और कमांड होती है
आपकी नेट स्टार्ट। आपकी एक कमांड होती है
नेट एक उसके बाद फॉर स्लैश और हफन देखिए
एक और ये कमांड है नेट कमांड। दिस
सिंटेक्स ऑफ़ दिस कमांड इज़ अकाउंट कम
कंप्यूटर कॉन्फ़िग कंटिन्यू फेल स्टार्ट।
आप इसका भी यूज़ कर सकते हो सर्विज की
इनेशन देखने के लिए। नेट स्टार्ट हिट एंटर
जैसे करोगे तो जितनी भी सर्विज है आपकी
मशीन में रनिंग सर्विज है उनकी इनेशन आपको
ये प्रोवाइड कर रहे हैं। देखिए यहां पर
पावर है, प्रिंस प्रिंस स्पूलर है, सर्वर
सर्विस है, टास्क शेड्यूलर है, थीम्स है,
टाइम ब्रोकर है, Windows डिफेंडर फायर वाल
है, Windows इवेंट लोग है, Windows टाइम
है, वर्क स्टेशन है, वर्ल्ड वाइड वेब
पब्लिशिंग सर्विज है। ये सारी सारी सर्विज
आपकी रन कर रही हैं। मैं चाहूं तो
पर्टिकुलर सर्विस को इससे भी स्टॉप कर
सकता हूं। नेक्स्ट स्टॉप उसके बाद स्पूलर
सर्विस को मैं क्या कर सकता हूं? स्टॉप कर
सकता हूं। प्रिंसपुलर सर्विस इज़ स्टॉपिंग
दी प्रिंटर सर्विस वाज़ स्टॉप सक्सेसफुली।
अगर आप इसका स्टेटस चेक करोगे तो आप आपको
पता है कैसे स्टेटस चेक कर सकते हैं। ये
रहा स्पुलर यहां पर देखोगे अभी स्टॉप्ड हो
गई। ये अभी क्या है? स्टॉप कंडीशन में है।
अब मैं फिर से इसको स्टार्ट करना चाहूं तो
क्या है? नेट स्टार्ट। उसके बाद सर्विस का
नाम। किस सर्विस को मैं स्टार्ट करना
चाहता हूं? स्पूलर हिट एंटर जैसे हमने
रिप्रिंट स्प्लर सर्विस स्टार्टिंग
स्टार्ट सक्सेसफुली अगर मैं इसका स्टेटस
चेक करना चाहता हूं तो एससी क्यूरी स्पूलर
ये काफी हेल्पफुल कमांड्स रहेंग जब आप पेन
टेस्टिंग करोगे जब आप खास करके लinक्स ये
Windows प्रीज एस्केलेशन करोगे एडवांस
लेवल पर जहां पर आप सर्विज को एक्सप्लइट
करने की कोशिश करते हो या सर्विज को
मिसकॉन्फ़िगर सर्विज को क्या करते हो?
हाईजैक करने की कोशिश करते हो। तो उस टाइम
पर रजिस्ट्री को हाईजैक करने की कोशिश
करते हो तो देयर आर लॉट ऑफ चांसेस कि वहां
पर आपको एडमिन एक्सेस मिलते हैं और कुछ
वीक सर्विस सर्विज भी आपको मिलेंगी। वीक
परमिशंस भी मिलेंगी आपको वीक रजिस्ट्री भी
मिलेंगी। डीएलएल हाईजैक भी करोगे तब भी तो
ये सारी सीएलआर की कमांड आपके उसमें काम
में आएंगी। तो ये सारी कमांड आपको समझ में
आ गई होगी। नेक्स्ट एक कमांड होती है
डब्ल्यू
एमआईसी। ठीक है? Windows मैनेजमेंट
इंस्ट्रूमेंशन कुछ कमांड होती है इसे।
डब्ल्यूएमआईसी कमांड होती है। उससे भी आप
क्या कर सकते हो? बहुत सारी इंफॉर्मेशन
देख सकते हो सिस्टम के अंदर। कैसे? फॉर
एग्जांपल
डब्ल्यूएमआईसी उसके बाद मैं एक बार क्लियर
कर लेता हूं स्क्रीन को क्लीन। यहां तक
सबको कमांड समझ में आ रही है या नहीं आ
रही? प्लीज मुझे बता दीजिए।
यहां तक सबको कमांड समझ में आ रही है या
नहीं आ रही? प्लीज मुझे बता दीजिए।
स्पर को क्या क्लियर कर देना? मैं आपको
बता रहा हूं कि आप कैसे भी प्रोसेस किसी
भी सर्विस को स्टार्ट और स्टॉप कर सकते हो
कमांड की हेल्प से। मैं किसी सर्विस को
एक्सप्लेन नहीं कर रहा। आप जो प्रिंट करते
हो उसके लिए एक सर्विस रन करती है। प्रिंट
जब कंट्रोल पी करते हो प्रिंट कमांड उससे
लिए कमांड वो करती है। आपकी सर्विस रन
करती है। उससे रिलेटेड सर्विज है। मैं
किसी पर्टिकुलर सर्विस को एक्सप्लेन नहीं
कर रहा। शुभम मैं सब यह बता रहा हूं कि
अगर आपको सर्विज दिखती है तो पर्टिकुलर
सर्विज को क्या कर सकते हो? कैसे स्टॉप
कैसे आप स्टार्ट कर सकते हो। ओके।
स्टार्ट कंटिन्यू करें। क्लास को कंटिन्यू
करें।
ओके
तो अभी हम इस डब्ल्यू एमआईसी जो कमांड है
इसकी हेल्प से क्या कर सकते हैं? इसकी
हेल्प से भी हम बहुत सारी इंफॉर्मेशन ले
सकते हैं क्योंकि बहुत बड़ा ब्रॉड टॉपिक
है। इसकी हेल्प से हम क्या कर सकते हैं?
बहुत सारी इंफॉर्मेशन ले सकते हैं। अभी
मैं आपकी अगर चाहूं तो कमेंट्स पैरेलल में
देख भी सकता हूं। ये रहा आपको दिख जाएंगी
मेरी कमेंट। मेरे को आपके कमेंट दिख
जाएंगी। आपको जैसे ही आएंगी कोई भी कमेंट।
ओके
चलो अभी डब्ल्यू एमआईसी कमांड की हेल्प से
आप क्या-क्या दे सकते हो जैसे कि मैं देख
सकता हूं डब्ल्यूएमआईसी कमांड उसके बाद
कंप्यूटर
सिस्टम एक कमांड है
कंप्यूटर सिस्टम उसके बाद गेट उसके बाद
मैं उसका क्या चाहता हूं मॉडल देखना चाहता
हूं मॉडल इंफॉर्मेशन मैन्युफैक्चरर
इंफॉर्मेशन
मैन्युफैक्चरर उसके बाद
नेम उसके बाद नेम हिट एंटर देखिए यहां पर
वीएमवेयर वीएमवेयर 2001 ये इसका नाम है
ठीक है wmआईसी कंप्यूटर सिस्टम गेट मॉडल
मैन्युफैक्चर नेम ओके ये रहा इस तरीके से
आप क्या कर सकते हो यह देख सकते हो
पर्टिकुलर इंफॉर्मेशनेशन किसी भी सिस्टम
की जैसे कि मैं बायस का सेल नंबर देखना
चाहता हूं जो आपका बायस होता है। डब्ल्यू
एमआईसी अभी यह क्या है कि एक चिटशीट होती
है। आप Google करोगे Google भी आपको
Google पे भी ये चिटशीट आपको मिल जाएगी
आसानी से। चैट जीपीटी करोगे चैट जीपीटी पर
भी ये चिटशीट आपको मिल जाएगी। आपको ये
सारी कमांड मिल जाएंगी। जैसे आपको बायoस
बायoस के अंदर मैं क्या करना चाहता हूं?
गेट करना चाहता हूं। सेल
नंबर सीरियल नंबर मैं अगर बायस का सेल
नंबर मेंशन देखना चाहता हूं। तो हिट एंटर
देखिए। ओके। डब्ल्यू एमआईसी ओके सॉरी फॉर
दैट।
यह रहा यह मेरा बायो इस पर्टिकुलर मशीन का
बायो सीरियल नंबर है। अगर आप अह ऑपरेटिंग
सिस्टम की और भी जानकारी लेना चाहते हो,
तो वह भी ले सकते हो। इस कमांड की हेल्प
से डब्ल्यूएमआई सी। उसके बाद जैसे हमने
क्या किया? ओएस गेट इंफॉर्मेशन कौन सी
इंफॉर्मेशन चाहिए आपको? जैसे कि
कैप्शन कैप्शन इंफॉर्मेशन जैसे कि वर्जन
ये चिट है मेरे पास। इसलिए उससे ही देख के
आपको मेरे को सारी कमांडें याद नहीं है।
मैं जस्ट चिट चिट की हेल्प से ही हमेशा
क्या करता हूं? देख के पेन टेस्टिंग करता
हूं। हिट एंटर देखिए बिल्ड नंबर यह है।
कैप्शन क्या है? Microsoft Windows सर्वर
2019 डाटा सेंटर एवोलशन उसका वर्जन। इस
तरीके से आप इस कमांड की हेल्प से क्या कर
सकते हो? ये सारी इनेशन देख सकते हो। लाइक
दैट अगर आपको यह देखना है कि कौन-कौन से
सॉफ्टवेयर इंस्टॉल्ड हैं कि तो उसके लिए
भी कमांड होती है आपकी wmआईसी। इसके अंदर
प्रोडक्ट प्रोडक्ट उसके बाद देन गेट उसके
बाद
नेम उसके बाद वर्जन
हिट एंटर यह देखो अरे
यार टाइपो एरर यह रहा नो इंस्टेंस अवेलेबल
इससे रिलेटेड आपको कुछ भी इंफॉर्मेशन नहीं
मिल रही तो नहीं है इंफॉर्मेशन जैसे आपको
क्या देखना है बैटरी स्टेटस भी देख सकते
हो जैसे कि देखो अगर आप देख पाओ तो एक
बैटरी
लेकिन यह हमारी ज्यादा कंसर्न कमांड नहीं
रहती मैं जस्ट आपको बता देता हूं
एलियस नॉट फाउंड इससे रिलेटेड कुछ भी
एलियस फाउंड नहीं है। आप तो नेटवर्क की
इंफॉर्मेशन भी देख सकते हो इससे आप चाहो
तो जैसे
कि आईसी उसके बाद नेट नेटवर्क ओ निक कार्ड
उसके
बाद क्या बफरिंग हो रहा है यार जगत गुरु
जी आपका नेटवर्क का इशू यहां पर कोई भी
बफरिंग नहीं है कंटीन्यूअसली हर चीज
कंटीन्यूअसली चल रही है आप अपना नेटवर्क
चेक
कीजिए बाकी सभी स्टूडेंट्स से पूछिए सबके
सिस्टम में कंटीन्यूअसली चल रहा है मैं
पैरेलल में स्क्रीन पे देख पा रहा हूं। तो
कुछ भी बफरिंग नहीं है। कुछ भी चीजें नहीं
रुक रही। तो प्लीज क्लास एक बार बता
दीजिए। बफरिंग है कुछ?
ओके। तो देखिए डब्ल्यू एमआईसी अभी फिर से
मैंने वही गड़बड़
किया एमआईसी निक गेट अब मुझे क्या-क्या
चाहिए नेटवर्क इनेशन में नेम उसके बाद मैं
चाहूं तो मेक
एड्रेस मैक एड्रेस
ओके नेम
ओके वेट वेट मशीन इज गॉट स्टक्ड मशीन इज
गॉट स्टक
ओके कनेक्शन इज ब्रेक ओके होल्ड
ऑन माय मशीन कनेक्शन
ओके चलो वर्किंग फाइन नाउ
ओके ओके ओके नाउ परफेक्टली
फाइन फिर से इसको मुझे सेट करना पड़ेगा
ये रहा शायद अभी आपके लिए सही रहेगा यह
परफेक्टली फाइन
ये रहा अभी हम क्या करते हैं जो कमांड थी
आपकी नेटवर्क इनेशन रिलेटेड डब्ल्यू
एमआईसी उसके बाद निक गेट उसके बाद
नेम देन फॉललोड बाय बाय मैक
एड्रेस मैक एड्रेस उसके बाद फॉललोड बाय
एडप्टर
टाइप एडप्टर टाइप और भी बहुत सारी कमांड्स
है मैं जस्ट आपको डेमो दे रहा हूं कि
डब्ल्यूएमआईसी कमांड की हेल्प से भी क्या
कर सकते हो इन देख लो इथर
80802.3 मैक एड्रेस नेम क्या है कर्नल
डिबगिंग नेटवर्क अपर ओके आप चाहो तो और भी
इंफॉर्मेशन देख सकते हो जैसे कि अभी आप
प्रोसेस की इंफॉर्मेशन भी देख सकते हो।
डब्ल्यू
एमआईसी उसके बाद
प्रोसेस प्रोसेस
लिस्ट ब्रीफ देखिए हिट एंटर यह देखिए यहां
पर प्रोसेस से भी आपकी इनेशन देखने को मिल
रही है। जैसे हमने लास्ट इंडिविजुअल एससी
कमांड और नेट स्टार्ट कमांड की हेल्प से
भी या टास्क लिस्ट कमांड्स की हेल्प से
हमने देखा था। उसके बाद अगर हम चाहे तो और
भी बहुत सारी चीजें देख सकते हैं। ग्रुप्स
पैचेस फॉर एग्जांपल मुझे Windows इंस्टॉल
की इनेशन देखनी है। आईसी उसके बाद एक
कमांड होती है कफ ई उसके बाद लिस्ट इस
कमांड का मैं यूज़ कर सकता हूं। हिट एंटर
देखिए ये आपके पैचेस से रिलेटेड इनेशन हॉट
फिक्स की बात कर रहा हूं मैं। होस्ट
फिक्सेस से रिलेटेड आपकी इनेशन दिखा रहा
है। देखो यहां पर इंस्टॉल डेट कब इसको
इंस्टॉल किया गया था? उसका क्या नाम था?
स्टेटस क्या है? हॉट फिक्स आईडी क्या है
उसकी? हॉट फिक्स आईडी क्या है? अभी क्या
है? काफी ज़ूम होगी मशीन इसलिए आपको इस
तरीके से देखने को मिल रही है सारी चीजें।
नाउ अभी मैं क्लियर कर देता हूं स्क्रीन
को। अभी मैं आपको दिखाता हूं सबसे
मोस्टेंट जो कमांड्स हैं जो सबसे मोस्टेंट
रहती है आपकी प्रायोरिटी। पर ये तो थी एक
छोटी सी झलक आपकी डब्ल्यू एमआईसी जो कमांड
है उसकी। इसके ऊपर भी आप चाहो तो
डेडिकेटेड चिट मिल जाएगी आपको। आप Google
करोगे तो तो आपको मैं अगर मैं इंफॉर्मेशन
प्रोवाइड करूं अगर आपको Windows की कमांड
की मैं आपको बताता हूं
Windows
कमांड
प्र्ट कमांड्स और अगर आप देखोगे तो एक इधर
भी एक चीज़ हुई सीएलआई सीएलआई इधर एवरीथिंग
फॉर फाउंड फाउंड ये
रहा एक तो तो ये काफी डिटेल्स चिटशीट
अवेलेबल्स है। आप इसको भी यूज़ कर सकते हो।
ये देखिए ये रहा कंट्रोल वी। एक मैं आपको
ये सेंड कर रहा हूं। एक और है Windows की
कमांड की चिटशीट जो आप वहां से भी देख
सकते हो। बहुत सारी मिल जाएंगी आपको। ये
रहा यहां पर आपको शायद 250 प्लस कमांडेड
कमांड्स होंगी। यहां पर इनका भी यूज़ कर
सकते हो। देखो इन कमांड्स का भी आप। ये
सारी सारी Windows की कमांड है। तो शायद
मुझे जरूरत ही नहीं है आपको समझाने की
इसके बाद। ओके? तो आपको मिल गई
चिटशीट मिल गई
ना उसके बाद मुझे एक यूजर और ग्रुप को
कैसे मैनेज किया जाता है आपकी Windows CLI
के अंदर Windows कमांड प्र्ट के अंदर अगर
मुझे यह देखना है कि मेरी मशीन के अंदर
कौन-कौन से यूज़र्स अवेलेबल्स है उसके लिए
कमांड होती है नेट यूज़र्स नेट यूज़र्स
कमांड होती है एक नेट यूजर हिट एंटर किया
तो मेरी मशीन के अंदर अभी
एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर्स बॉब वन बॉब टू पार्ट
पार्टनर वन, कैश, डिफॉल्ट काउंट और ये
सारे यूज़र्स अभी अवेलेबल्स हैं। ओके? अगर
मुझे ग्रुप्स की इनेशन देखनी है कि मेरी
मशीन में कौन-कौन से ग्रुप्स अवेलेबल्स
हैं, तो हम क्या करेंगे? नेट लोकल ग्रुप।
लोकल ग्रुप हम ये कमांड रन करेंगे। हिट
एंटर करेंगे। तो मेरी मशीन में इतने सारे
लोकल ग्रुप्स अवेलेबल्स हैं। देखिए एक्सेस
कंट्रोल असिस्टेंस ऑपरेटर,
एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर्स, बैकअप ऑपरेटर्स,
क्रिप्टोग्राफिक ऑपरेटर्स, डिवाइस ओनर्स
इतने सारे ग्रुप्स होते हैं। गेस्ट है,
आईएस यूज़र्स हैं, पावर यूज़र्स है। उसके
बाद प्रिंट्स ऑपरेटर्स है, रिमोट डेस्कटॉप
यूज़र्स है, रिमोट मैनेजमेंट यूज़र्स है,
यूज़र्स हैं। दे आर लॉट ऑफ़ ग्रुप्स आर
अवेलेबल्स। ओके? अभी मुझे यह देखना है।
अभी देखना नहीं मुझे अभी क्या करना एक
पर्टिकुलर यूजर को क्रिएट करना है। तो मैं
कैसे कर सकता हूं? नेट उसके बाद यूजर उसके
बाद हम एक कमांड यूज़ करेंगे। डेमो यूजर
डेमो यूजर उसके बाद उसका पासवर्ड पासवर्ड
मैंने रखा टेस्ट @ 1 2 3 और उसके बाद
नेक्स्ट फॉरवर्ड स्लैश और ऐड करना है। तो
यह मेरा एक यूजर ऐड हो जाएगा। देखो दी
कमांड सक्सेसफुली सक्सेस हो गया। अभी मैं
चेक करना चाहूं तो मैं चेक कर सकता हूं
कैसे नेट यूज़र्स हिट एंटर नेट यूजर देखिए
एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर बॉब वन बॉब टू गेस्ट डेमो
यूजर ये यूज़र्स भी आपको देखने को मिलेगा
नेक्स्ट अगर आप चाहो तो क्या कर सकते हो
इस पर्टिकुलर यूज़र्स को किसी ग्रुप के साथ
ऐड भी कर सकते हो मैंने क्या किया कि इसको
मैं एडमिनिस्ट्रेट ग्रुप का भी पार्ट बना
सकता हूं कैसे अभी देखो कि अभी
नेट लोकल ग्रुप
लोकल लोकल ग्रुप उसके बाद मेरा रहेगा
एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर ए डी एम आई एन आई एस टी आर
ए टी ओ एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर्स देन उसका डेमो
यूजर को मैंने बनाया डेमो यूजर थिट एंटर
देखिए ओके ओके कुछ हमने गड़बड़ किया है
लोकल ग्रुप्स है लोकल ग्रुप है
नेट लोकल ग्रुप
ओके ओके ऐड करना है फॉरवर्ड स्लैश ऐड फिट
एंटर अभी हमने सक्सेसफुली ऐड हो गया अभी
मैं चेक करना चाहता हूं कि एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर
अकाउंट है उसके मेंबर्स कौन-कौन से हैं?
उस ग्रुप के मेंबर्स कौन-कौन से हैं? मैं
कैसे देख सकता हूं?
नेट लोकल ग्रुप उसके बाद एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर
यह
देखिए एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर और डेमो यूजर
एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर्स और डेमो यूज़र्स दो ही
इसके मेंबर्स हैं। देखो एलियास नेम
एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर्स है। एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर हैव
कंप्लीट एन अनरिस्ट्रिक्टेड एक्सेस टू द
पीसी और डोमेन। अभी दो यूज़र्स अब मैं इसको
रिमूव कैसे कर सकता हूं? इसको मैं रिमूव
भी कर सकता हूं। कैसे कर सकता हूं? नेट
लोकल
ग्रुप उसके बाद नेट लोकल ग्रुप उसके बाद
मैं क्या करता हूं एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर कमांड
मैं वापस रिपीट कर लेता हूं ना ये रहा
इसको मैं डिलीट कर सकता हूं यहां पर कमांड
यूज़ कर सकता हूं नेट लोकल ग्रुप
एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर डेमो यूज़र्स उसको मैं क्या
कर सकता हूं डिलीट इस ग्रुप का मेंबर था
ये अभी इस ग्रुप का मेंबर यह नहीं बचेगा
अगर मैं इसको फिर से चेक करूंगा यह
देखो अभी यह इस ग्रुप का मेंबर
नहीं है। अभी मैं चाहूं तो इस ग्रुप को
इनएक्टिव कर सकता हूं। इनक्टिव कैसे कर
सकता हूं? इसके लिए मेरी कमांड होती है हम
हम
हां नेट यूजर
डेमो यूजर उसके बाद फॉलो
स्लश एक्टिव ये उसके बाद नो इस तरीके से
हम कर सकते हैं। हिट एंटर देखिए कमांड
कंप्लीटेड सक्सेसफुली। अभी यह इनक्टिव है।
अभी यह क्या कर टेंपरेरी किसी भी वजह से
अभी क्या यह लॉग इन नहीं कर पाएगा इस मशीन
के अंदर। इस पर्टिकुलर यूज़र्स को मैं क्या
कर सकता हूं? डिलीट भी कर सकता हूं। कैसे?
नेट यूजर और यहां पर मैं क्या कर सकता
हूं? डिलीट
डिलीट और किसी यूजर को मैं क्रिएट भी कर
सकता हूं। नेट
लोकल लोकल ग्रुप यूज़र्स नहीं सॉरी फॉर
एग्जांपल मैं किसी ग्रुप को क्रिएट कर
सकता हूं। नेट लोकल ग्रुप उसके बाद ग्रुप
नेम उसके बाद फोर स्लश हेल्प ऐड हम कर
सकते हैं। तो इस तरीके से हम क्या कर सकते
हैं? किसी भी यूज़र्स को वो भी कर सकते हैं
या लोकल ग्रुप को ऐड कर सकते हैं। तो सबको
समझ में आ गया किसी भी ग्रुप के मेंबर्स
को कैसे देख सकते हो। किसी भी ग्रुप्स
कितने ग्रुप्स क्रिएट हुए हैं वो भी देख
सकते हो। कितने यूज़र्स आपकी मशीन में वो
भी देख सकते हो और किसी भी नए यूज़र्स को
कैसे क्रिएट और डिलीट कर सकते हो। आप चाहो
तो अपने जो एग्जिस्टिंग यूज़र्स हैं आप
एडमिन हो। आप चाहो तो पासवर्ड भी चेंज कर
सकते हो। यहां तक सबको क्लियर
है? यहां तक सबको क्लियर है?
यहां तक सबको क्लियर
है? किसी को कोई डाउट? सबको कमा कमांड समझ
में आ रही है?
सबको कमान समझ में आ रही है?
ओके तो ये थी आपकी बेसिक कमांड ऑफ
सीएमडी बिल्कुल सही रहेगा मान सिंह आप ऐसा
कर पाओ तो दिस इज परफेक्टली फाइन
ओके यह थी आपकी
सीएमडी की बेसिक कमांड यूज। तो नेक्स्ट
टाइम से अगर आपको बोला जाए कि Windows
कमांड प्र्ट पर कौन-कौन सी सर्विज रन कर
रही हैं? कौन से प्रोसेस रन कर रही हैं?
कौन-कौन से यूज़र्स एक्सिस्ट करते हैं? और
भी अदर डिटेल्स मशीन का वर्जन क्या है?
फाइल डायरेक्टरी के ऊपर या मशीन के अंदर
नेवि नेविगेट करना आपको। एक डायरेक्टरी से
दूसरे डायरेक्टरी में, एक फोल्डर से दूसरे
फोल्डर में। तो आप कैसे कर सकते हो? कर
पाओगे। किसी भी फाइल की परमिशन देख
पाओगे। सब कंफर्टेबल
हो।
एवरीवन सभी देख पाओगे।
यहां तक किसी का कोई डाउट है रिलेटेड टू
योर क्लास।
Windows की कमांड में किसी का कोई डाउट है
कि किसी को समझ में नहीं आया हो या लगता
कि सर Windows की कमांड बोरिंग थी। हमें
कमांड प्रैक्टिस नहीं कर पाएंगे या हमें
किसी ऐसा कुछ लगता है सब लोग प्रैक्टिस कर
पाओगे Windows की कमांड
पे?
एवरीवन शुभम वो मैं रजिस्ट्री
का बता दूंगा मैं कमांड। वैसे हार्ड नहीं
है। रजिस्ट्री की अलग कमांड होती है
क्योंकि वो मैं इसलिए नहीं पढ़ाया। ज्यादा
चीजें ओवर हो जाएंगी। रजिस्ट्री को हम
क्या करते हैं? बहुत सारी कमांड ऐसी आएंगी
जब हम पेन टेस्टिंग कर रहे होंगे विंडोज
मशीन की। उस टाइम पे काफी हेल्पफुल होंगी।
उस टाइम पे हम यूज़
करेंगे। शेयर करना चाहते हो आप? मेरे को
Lindin पे शेयर कर दो।
मैसेज में विनोद
कुमार नेक्स्ट वीडियो से हम Windows की
पेन टेस्टिंग स्टार्ट कर रहे
हैं। नेक्स्ट क्लास से हम Windows की पेन
टेस्टिंग स्टार्ट कर रहे हैं। यहां तक
हमने फंडामेंटल्स ओवर कर दिए। दे आर टोटल
सेवन क्लास। जहां तक हमने Windows के
बेसिक फंडामेंटल्स को क्या कर दिया?
क्लियर कर दिया। Windows में पढ़ने के लिए
तो और भी बहुत कुछ है। बहुत सारी चीजें
हैं। बट बेसिक लेवल पर जितना मैंने आपको
पढ़ाना था Windows फंडामेंटल के बारे में।
Windows की सर्विज कैसे क्या होती हैं?
प्रोसेस क्या क्या होती है? Windows की
रजिस्ट्री क्या होती है? डीएल फाइल क्या
होती हैं? और Windows की सीएमडी में कमांड
कैसे रन करती हैं? उसकी बूटिंग प्रोसेस
कैसे काम करती है? ये सारी चीजें बेसिक
लेवल पर मैं आपको बताना चाहता था। एक
इंटरेस्ट बनाना चाहता था Windows के
फंडामेंटल्स के अंदर। ओके? उसके
बाद अभी हम स्टार्ट करने वाले हैं Windows
की पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टिंग। Windows
फंडामेंटल के बाद हम स्टार्ट कर रहे हैं
Windows की पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टिंग। क्योंकि
अभी Windows में पढ़ने के लिए तो बहुत कुछ
है। पढ़ भी बहुत कुछ सकते हो। बट आपको
ओवरव्यू मिल गया होगा कि Windows को कैसे
यूज़ किया जाता है। Windows के बिहाइंड दी
सीन चीजें कैसे काम करती हैं। कैसे सर्विज
डीएलएल्स होती क्या है? कभी आपको एक नाम
सुनने को मिलेगा डीएलएल सर्विज उसके बाद
रजिस्ट्री देन उसके बाद कई बार आपको बायस
की फाइल बूटिंग सीक्वेंस तो यह चीजें आपको
सुनेगी आपको सुनने को मिलेगी तो शायद आप
कभी कंफ्यूज नहीं होंगे Windows की पेन
टेस्टिंग के
दौरान हां यूडीटेक क्लास ओवर हो गया यू
कैन लीव
तो अगर अभी तक की क्लास से रिलेटेड आपको
कोई भी सवाल हो, किसी का कोई भी डाउट्स है
तो मुझसे पूछ सकता है। नेक्स्ट क्लास से
हम Windows पेन टेस्टिंग स्टार्ट करेंगे।
कौन सी कंपनी का ऐप
है? विनोद ठाकुर
शुभम रजिस्ट्री में क्या चीज समझ में नहीं
आई? रजिस्ट्री में क्या क्लियर नहीं हुआ?
रजिस्ट्री बहुत ही सिंपल है। कॉन्फ़िगरेशंस
आपकी Windows की। आप Windows में चाहे आप
डेस्कटॉप की इमेज चेंज करते हो, चाहे आप
कुछ भी काम करते हो, कोई सॉफ्टवेयर रन
करते हो, कुछ भी काम करते हो या कुछ भी
मॉडिफिकेशन करते हो, डायरेक्टली और
इनडायरेक्टली वो Windows की रजिस्ट्री के
थ्रू ही हो रहा है। जब आप कभी कंट्रोल
पैनल्स में कुछ भी प्रोग्राम्स या कुछ भी
सेटिंग्स कुछ भी चेंज करते हो, सब कुछ
आपका क्या है? Windows की सेटिंग हो तो
Windows रजिस्ट्री के थ्रू ही होता है। वह
आपके पूरे सिस्टम्स की कॉन्फ़िगरेशंस
फाइल्स
हैं। नहीं आपका कमेंट शो हो रहा है मानस
सिंह। ऐसा कुछ नहीं
है। तो बताइए किसी और कोई सवाल है या सेशन
को एंड करें?
किसी का कोई सवाल
है? शुभम अभी आपको एसआईडी आरआईडी समझ में
नहीं आएगी। एडवांस में जाओगे तभी समझ में
आएगी।
यह डीप है। बहुत ज्यादा डीप लेवल का
कांसेप्ट
है। अभी इतना ही मान के चलिए। हर एक यूजर
की अपनी एक एसआईडी होती है। आपका सिस्टम
आपके यूजर को नेम से नहीं एसआईडी से जानता
है। बस इतना मान के चलिए। और एसआईडी से
पहले आर आईडी होती है किसी भी यूजर के
लिए। वह उस आरआईडी के थ्रू ही उस एसआईडी
को फाइंड आउट किया जाता है। और यह सारी
यूनिक होती है।
अरे राज रोहन आप कितनी बार यहां स्पैमिंग
कर रहे हो? हमने आपको बोला है कि आपको पेन
टेस्टिंग सीखनी है तो डे वन से स्टार्ट
कीजिए
यार। की बात समझ में नहीं आ
रही। कभी आप नंबर मांग रहे हो, कभी इंस्टा
आईडी मांग रहे हो। जब आपको बता दिया गया
है कि आपको सिंपली डे वन से आपको क्लासेस
नहीं मिल रही क्या? YouTube पे डेफोनिस्ट
एकडमी सर्च करो। आपको नहीं मिलती।
डेफ्रोनिस्ट एकडमी पर आपको जाना है
YouTube पर।
डेफोनिस्ट एकडमी है यह। यह देखो इतनी सारी
क्लासेस तो हैं। तो कहीं से भी स्टार्ट कर
सकते हो। देर 37 क्लासेस यहां पर होगी आज
की क्लास के साथ। डीई एच ई डेफ एथिकल हैक
एसेंशियल्स। आप इसको डे वन से स्टार्ट
कीजिए और आप यह डे वन से नहीं कर सकते तो
फिर हम क्या बताएं?
तो एक काम करते हैं अभी सेशन को एंड करते
हैं। आपके कोई भी क्वरी नहीं है तो कोई भी
सवाल जवाब नहीं है तो आपका तो फिर भी अगर
आपके डाउट्स हैं तो आप कमेंट सेक्शन में
पूछ सकते हैं सेशन ओवर होने के बाद
रिकॉर्डिंग अवेलेबल रहती है YouTube पर।
लाइफ टाइम एक्सेस रहेगा आपका रिकॉर्डिंग
पर।
तो आपको दोस्त चाहिए तो स्पेंड मनी पैसे
से कोर्स खरीदो। उसके बाद आप उस कोर्स में
ज्वाइन हो जाओ। उसके बाद ही कोर्स
ड्यूरेशन के लिए ही आपको मिलता है कोई भी
इंसान। आप किसी को पर्सनल पेमेंट फीस पे
नहीं करोगे ना। जो आपके सारे डाउट्स हमेशा
24 * 7 आपके डाउट्स क्लियर करेगा तो आप
उसको पेमेंट नहीं कर रहे ना।
ओके बकवास बंद करो यार। ठीक है आपको जस्ट
पासिंग माय टाइम सबको डिस्टर्ब कर रहे हो
इधर।
ओके हम सेशन को ओवर करते हैं। बाय-बाय एंड
सी यू फॉर नेक्स्ट क्लास। जल्द ही हम
नेक्स्ट क्लास में मिलेंगे डे 38 में जहां
पर हम Windows पेन टेस्टिंग स्टार्ट
करेंगे फ्रॉम स्टार्टिंग।
ओके तो बाय बाय थैंक यू एंड गुड नाइट सी
यू फॉर नेक्स्ट सेशन